yeah that smelled like transmission
fluid ask him and you open it you're
like oh god dog you eat these [__]
things people tell you how do you eat
for I told the lady at perennial that
you weighed two of them yeah
I can't even imagine that she goes I got
a square and cut it into twos yeah and I
go she goes I get [__] up for four or
five hours straight but you know what's
weird I had what did I have I had three
of the red Stars last night that's just
375 I have 375. just to warm up for
nothing I got pretty high for like four
hours after two it hits you but then it
goes away real fast right yeah
absolutely it disappears real fast yeah
we burn through these Stars we our main
edible are the stars so we built the
dollar this time like most people could
eat one red one and they get they see
but I mean isn't it THC though because
like I have a I have an extreme
tolerance to smoking like I can [__]
smoke yeah dude I could smoke all
literally all day I just the only reason
I don't do it anymore is because like my
throat'll start to hurt yeah I'm not
getting nowhere I'll get a headache you
know that first time in the morning is
my best I got super high in the morning
I do all the little things I have to do
while I'm high if I hit it again I get a
little high but once I come back from
Jiu Jitsu I hit the pipe maybe once you
ever you ever take a break just to get
really highly because I sometimes I took
that break for like six months and how
did it work oh no when I came back I got
really freaking out
yeah for a week you're [__] Stone
you're eating your fingers yeah it's
great ready I'm ready let's do this
let's do this [__]
we wanna we wanna start yakim while the
[__] thing's hitting you the Church
of What's Happening Now is presented by
on it
this show is also brought to you by hint
water go to hint.com charge and check
out hint water hint water is a brand new
water that brings you the fresh Taste of
fruit with pure water and right now when
you go to hint.com church you're going
to get a variety pack of their most
popular
flavors for only fifteen dollars it's
normally 24. drinkhint.com Church show
is also brought to you by mandies
go to meandies.com Joey right now to get
20 off of your first order shipping is
always free in the US and Canada go to
meandies.com Joey right now check out
their shirts their socks their underwear
I love their sweatpants go to
meandies.com Joey right now
everybody
here we go
Mr Gomez is in studio
kick that mulee don't make me tell you
again kick that [__] I don't
care what the animal society says kick
that [__] it's Thursday night
December 8th what
oh [__] Jews up and jumping up and down
you got [__] 16 more days to Yom
Kippur or Hanukkah one of those
[__]
one more star going we're at 1600
milligrams or Ripley call his mother
call Guinness
it's the Church of What's Happening Now
[__] oh [__]
black people jumping up and down
[Music]
oh [__] break out the Gorilla Biscuits
here we go do it do it Mr G
what you did to me cause I'm not the
same oh [__]
[Music]
you just don't know
oh [__]
you wanted you got it and [__] we've
been doing bong hits stars of death
we've been taking good care of Mr Gino
we don't want to kill him tonight we
want him to make the plane tomorrow I
I'm you know what I keep on getting
warned about this show over and that's
the one thing I've gotten is like listen
to me don't have anything to do after
the show make sure your flight's not too
early the next day don't drink the water
because Joey might put acid in it
there's all of these we can't find the
acid we got rid of my mistake I don't
think so I think you put it in some
Waters it's like the Willy Wonka ticket
but you just put some ads into some
random there's like seven [__] hits
in this room in one of these bottles of
water no it's probably another one of
those couches I hit it
got hit it because we did it we got
paranoid so it's in one of the album
covers it's here though one day
somebody's gonna be very happy I was
moving furniture one time with Dave
Smith we used to be a roommates as a
comedian and one of my co-hosts some
other podcasts and uh he uh we were
moving our couch and as we're moving it
on the day we're moving a bag of cocaine
fell out of the couch like probably like
you know
a great ball
um and it was me heaven or buddy Wes and
literally we all sat we saw it fall on
the floor we all paused for exactly one
second and then we go for it all three
of us and we wrestled around on the
floor until one of us finally got it
um and then of course we just shared it
but we did a one we did a line each
immediately and then we felt guilty
because we didn't really do cocaine it
was a buddy of ours our drug dealer
friend jablonski he would [__] come
over with like tons of drugs all the
time and he accidentally dropped it on
our couch it was like a year old so then
we felt guilty and then we ended up
flushing it down the toilet the rest of
it you should have sold it yeah he split
60 a piece something I mean how would we
have sold it I don't know there's some
[__] money in the comedy club that'll
give you 50 bucks yeah but it's not it's
not enough if it was like a big bag of
cocaine there's no way we would have
flushed it was like all right let's
[__] figure three grams somebody
would give you 50 bucks for it yeah but
I would have had to go out and [__]
be Hawking weed at comedy clubs at all I
wasn't still I wasn't doing comedy I
have one friend that does coke everybody
has one creepy friend that does coke I
think I have one friend that doesn't do
Coke yeah so you call that don't call
him call everybody else and whoever gets
here first has a deal of a century bring
50 bucks and watch them come over it's
[__] crazy yeah I found the bag of
coke once I thought it was like meeting
God
you know what I'm saying like I'd rather
find you you have more chances of
finding money yeah than finding like two
grams of [__] blow like you go to
7-Eleven that's what it was yeah it was
10 years ago at the curse on 7-Eleven
and the [__] up thing you remember the
day oh my God I went in there and I went
in there the other day they had the
audacity and put the liners back up they
used to have NFL lighters I used to clip
two or [__] pop right instead of them
while I was paying they looked down I
take two hours hold on is this recently
no this was 10 years ago but they put
the lightest back this week because I
went in there Tuesday yeah and I said oh
[__] they got the light of this
background I was ready to clip on yeah
I'm like oh I [__] around at this point
in the game all right don't you just
kind of wanted because I do that
sometimes just to test my abilities
still if I could just like my cousin
just for no reason I do it all the time
for stupid [__] like I was I was the
other day I was with my chick and we
were at uh Rite Aid and there's like
nail polishes like up at the at the
front thing so for no reason right in
front of the check as I'm paying I grab
one of those polishes put it under my
it's I'm palming it that's what I'm
doing not a big deal putting it in your
hand like you're reaching for money just
nothing and you drop the [__] thing
and you take out the wall and they look
at you like
no he didn't have no nail polish it's
nice and simple put it in my [__]
crazy it's like Houdini I walk outside
give it a hers a nice little gift you
know and I'm being funny which is
hilarious she doesn't want nail
polishers nothing but for some reason I
still want to be able to test my ability
to see if I could do that
and I could I still do it I still it's a
terrible [__] I don't shop lift like
bags of chips I got an addiction for
just lettuce
just light as if you're dumb enough to
put a lighter in front of me I'll take
the space I go the 7-Eleven I go that
has little lighters out they even put
like when they're overflowed on lighters
they put they put them sideways yeah
which is like an invitation for a sucker
like me but I like them so much if I ask
them why they'd probably give it to me
so why Rob them you know yeah I I I'm
notorious at stealing people's lighters
like in life by mistake yeah yeah a
mistake on purpose not not on purpose I
don't care enough to give it back to
them you go out with a green light you
come home with a white lighter yeah and
it's filled and you're like who the [__]
took my life at least I came home with a
[__] life yeah that's a magical weed
that's why there you are connected with
weeds sometimes because sometimes you're
going with a red lighter
and you come home with a green light and
you're like what the [__]
I didn't lose anything maybe a little
bit of [__] butane you know so you're
looking pale over that dog I haven't
seen you this pal since the first time
you did kettlebells I'm just thinking
about
having so much coke that you don't
realize you dropped an eight ball like
I've I've never found like that I
couldn't imagine you're [__] up losing
drugs you're [__] up you're going
through your pockets you know you got an
eight ball in there you got a gram for
later you got three pills in there you
got cash you got weed you got rolling
papers you got a lighter you got a
wallet and it's all in there and you
take it out all night because you're
paranoid
yeah it happens man yeah you know I've
dropped Coke on a [__] couch or or
the move was uh you're doing it in the
bathroom you put it down on the the
thing in the bathroom and you forget you
put it down and you leave and that's it
then the next dude is taking a [__] just
as well you said that because I was just
thinking about
Chinese restaurant I used to deliver
food from deliver Coke for
and they have like a bat they had like
two bathrooms for customers then they
had a bathroom for Chinese people only
were they then they had another bathroom
for the women in the back but if you
went back back in the storage room that
little bathroom with a little it looks
like a closet it was just the toilet in
the sink
and I would go in there and weigh the
coke and I would put the coke on the
toilet it was white
and I would put the coke on the toilet
and do a couple lines and get ready to
deliver Chinese food
and one night I must have been in a rush
I came in two days later away Coke and
there was a line this big on that
[__] thing that unless you have a
train die yeah you're not gonna see that
wow unless you have a cocaine train if
I'm gonna die and they'll be that the
drugs they smoked pot from time to time
so yeah what's up Lee well you guys were
talking earlier about and I only did it
once flying with weed and the only time
I did it I I had some edibles I was
flying home and I got too paranoid like
you've always talked about how you just
put it underneath the plane like you
like before when you used to go back and
forth between Colorado and New York I
was too nervous I was like I don't want
to get there and then have them take my
luggage so I brought it in my backpack
but this is the only time this has ever
happened the TSA brought a second a
separate like scanner to the gate and
they were scanning random people at the
gate I was I couldn't have been more
scared I couldn't nail you right there
oh my God and then I got and then I
thought about you I got pulled over
today oh my God I just
I just I was so happy I wasn't stoned or
I I've never been have you been pulled
over Stone oh it's horrible oh
you start [__] mumbling and stumbling
I was doing that was the one thing that
I liked about stopping smoking weed it
was like six months that I didn't smoke
weed like and you and I forgot but like
I used to always have weed on me in New
York City it's you know it's gotten a
little better but like it's not Cali
dude Cali you guys are [__] like
partying out here it is like you don't
even get it dude you go to [__] New
York City bro I lit up one time and 20
people looked at me like I was a martian
yeah you're it's right by Opie and
Anthony right right down there [__]
criminal dude you know me I took a joint
out and of course [__] people looking
at me even in Jersey when I'm in
Edgewater I go outside and snow like
that Cali it's like you guys don't know
how good you have it if you haven't been
to New York if you go to New York City
you are it's like you're doing heroin
I'm assuming if you did heroin on the
streets of California it's how people
look at you if you're smoking weed in
New York City let me tell you something
okay
I was in New York City since 19 [__]
66.
you know
as a kid my mom took me to see the home
Globetrotters 40 seconds I went
everywhere
and there was a time in New York City
this is how New York how much New York
has changed
okay there was a time in New York City
when I was a child maybe six from the
age of six to maybe eleven and I'm not
exaggerating it
I spent my time within 88th Street and
Broadway that's where I went to school
P.S 166 but on the weekends I would go
to my godmothers at 148th
in the late in the mid 70s and this is a
no exaggeration ask your dad or your
uncles or somebody who remembers the 70s
in New York
you'd see a [__] heroin dude nodding
every four minutes I used to see it in
New York okay and I mean they were
everywhere yeah it was infested the
upper the Upper West Side I was wasn't a
big Upper East Side guys so I can't tell
you yeah I used to go to 116th and third
like by the park to get Coke from my
mom's friend but that was later on in
life nothing
heroin was a everywhere that's what you
saw
from
107th Street all the way to 178th Street
from Port Authority they would not as
the light was changing Mr Gomez not and
when the light would change they would
walk across the street and not again
yeah you would never it's like walking
dead that's what it was you saw two
Walking Dead people on every [__]
block but downtown New York all those
other West Side Up the you know 8th
Avenue you would smell weed all the time
when I was a kid 42nd Street would wreak
a [__] weed nobody ever said nothing
reek a wheat yeah when you made the
right onto and you saw that thing
spinning with the news the ticker and
you made the the left onto Broadway
whatever that is that would that would
be a drug dealer help yeah that was all
drug dealers then the 80s came in the
early 80s you could do blow anyway in
New York yeah
any club you went to if you went into
the woman's bathroom
there was four or five people doing blow
women wouldn't even say nothing
women wouldn't even say nothing it was
that open I left New York in 85 and
cocaine was wide open you could be at a
bar in Manhattan and take a package out
and do this and nobody would look at you
nobody would look at you weird because
that yuppie
mentality hadn't hit yet well now it's
an Elita sound like it's so [__]
expensive right it's so expensive to
live in New York now that it's like you
know it's you know it's become this like
and we with weird it's changing a little
I'll say it is changing okay because
you'll smell weed in the air now if you
go to certain areas you go to the West
Village Down By The Comedy Cellar you'll
see people smoking weed right it's not
it's a it's a little but not on 89th
Street you won't no no you ride a joint
by the stand you like I've been by the
stand I put a joint by the stand I got
arrested outside of the stand I can't go
to [__] Canada because of getting
arrested outside of the state what the
[__] you think I'm talking about that's
the upper west right that's 20th no
that's uh it's a grammar seat but yes
yes are you kidding me that was
heroinville when I was a kid yeah
I got arrested outside the stand I did
but I don't buy this for smoking weed
yeah well here's the thing right yeah
that's the point I told you this is why
I I like this is what I was saying
before I when I stopped smoking weed
yeah four uh two two stars guys two
stars I can't speak anymore okay so uh
no but when I uh when I wasn't smoking
weed I was walking around and you'd walk
past a cop and I was so used to being
fearful because I always had weed in my
pocket and now that I didn't have weed
in my pocket it was like a breath of
fresh air like I wasn't committing a
crime at all time so cops weren't making
me as nervous you know what I'm saying
but if it was a cop and I just literally
was coming coming like 10 feet with I
would get nervous if they could smell it
on me and it's not like you go to
[__] prison for smoking weed in New
York City but it [__] up your night
it'll [__] up your weekend if you get
caught on a Friday if you get caught
someone gonna join on a Friday night
you'll spend the weekend in jail the
weekend in jail until Monday yep it
[__] sucks and that's all it is it
sucks but if in Canada the rules are to
get in that country you can't get in no
I I can but I got to pay a few hundred
dollars a year and it's up to them they
could deny me the license it's a whole
bunch of [__] that I have to go
through now just to get to Canada
crazy
now let me ask you this because a friend
of mine said he went to
David Gilmore at the Garden he had
really good seats and somebody a little
join up and then looked at him like
[__] you can't do it at the Garden
you do the vape pen
I don't miss [__] vape pen
I Wanna smoke a vape pen like on a dick
in my ass
what are you [__] crazy
that's that's that's what I don't
understand
it's very dainty I used to get the
[__] cigarettes that women would
smoke in the 40s oh the like the long
[__] uh DeVille ones yeah yeah that's
what Vape ends up 94. I used to work on
11th Avenue where they sell all the cars
down there yeah okay and I used to get
out of Manhattan Jeep Eagle am I 40s
there's a diner on the corner there and
the hot dog man
I used to get off at work at nine seven
thirty sometimes 6 30.
and I remember walking up 57th Street by
the CBS building and [__] and dog
as soon as I walked out of that building
I was it's 1994 so that's 23 years ago I
was in my 30s
I'd walk out of there I'd make a left on
uh 11th Avenue the street would be
pretty empty until I hit 57th I started
walking up yeah as soon as I hit 57th I
sparked up yeah I remember standing in
front of that David Letterman building
sparking like smoking because it was too
cold yeah I didn't want to walk
and nobody said dick nobody looked at
their head well that's the problem with
like be like I'm addicted like that and
that's the problem and I've been
arrested for smoking weed like 10 times
like it's like people that smoke weed
don't do that like I I do it to the
point where
I if I'm going somewhere
and I know that I'm gonna be like on a
road trip for a while and I can't smoke
like I'll make them pull over and like
[__] stop at a restaurant yeah like
every time like I'm like I'm it's like
an addiction that's where that's where
it's not a good thing where I literally
need it every single day in the morning
you know I don't need alcohol yeah I
could stay off Coke for a few days but I
would never have to do it in the daytime
this is my [__] drug yeah since the
time I was 12 first time I smoked it I
knew it was me yeah same thing I knew it
was me alcohol for me is something that
was something I did with other drugs you
know but it's not something that I'm
gonna go into a bar and get a beer I
wish I could be one of those guys I grew
up in the 70s where
TV shows when you walked into a guy's
apartment he just turned around and
poured you a whiskey and gave it to you
yeah you didn't say was that southern
comfort you just drank yeah Okay so
I always I always wanted to be that guy
that could drink I can't drink yeah I
was drinking whiskey every night for the
past [__] like eight years almost
probably killing myself I really like
just [__] my body up because at
comedy clubs we don't pay for alcohol so
I'm drinking for free every night and um
you know for I just stopped drinking a
year it'll be January 22nd will be a
year I don't I don't look at it as even
being a big deal I don't understand like
it's not hard for me so I'm unapplotting
myself I'm not one of these people
that's gonna post it on Facebook and be
like oh look at what I did who gives a
[__] I'll probably make a stupid joke
about it but it's weed is hard every day
it was a struggle when I was not smoking
weed every single day when I got locked
up that was the hardest part of getting
locked up really
the thought of going to prison for me
because when I went to Boulder County
for those three weeks and waiting for my
bail to get reduced they were smoking
weed in there there's no drug testing
there yeah people getting arrested and
tucking weeding their ass home bringing
it in and you know what man like they
would charge you ten dollars for a joint
or something or Tender even now if you
go to just the tombs for the weekend or
the night I'm in New York City it's it
was like this is a while ago but it was
like I think it was like 20 or 30 bucks
for a joint and it was a little tiny bit
yeah
as small as it could be you have no idea
dude and we bought it dude me and
another guy yeah that's it done three
hits but it was great it was glorious
dude
cigarettes in jail or [__] the best
I didn't smoke cigarettes when I went to
prison I didn't even in 87 I didn't
dream of smoking cigarettes and that
wasn't even I couldn't even get in your
car if you smoke no I'm also comparing
my knight in Central Bookings to your
time in prison
you gotta let people know it ain't no
fun [__] jokes
people are trying to prove themselves it
sucks you might get killed at the tombs
because you might run into a guy who
don't give a [__] Lee he don't give a
[__] he's already got a murder well they
mix in guys
smoking weed you have no [__] idea
you're seeing NYU dude a guy like you if
you went and smoked a joint in
Washington Square Park which is a famous
place that people just get popped all
the time for smoking weed right and that
would be a place that you would go
because it seems like a place that's
pretty safe it seems like if you go look
at look at Washington Square Park look
at pictures it's a cool place to hang
out they got cool architecture they have
all those like [__] arches and [__]
smoking a joint out there it's like a
trap because it's it's the perfect place
to smoke a joint but they got undercover
cops all over there David Lee Roth got
arrested there for buying weed
I knew it was the end of civilization
you know in the [__] again and you
guys with you like a dinosaur in New
York this is why when I go to New York
now it's very nice and all but it's not
the place where I grew up in yeah I
don't know these people these people you
see walking around New York wouldn't
have walked around New York 30 years ago
yeah those people you see walking around
giggling on their phones that wouldn't
have been well I've been in New York
since 2001 right after 9 11 I moved
there and even in the time that I've
been there which is like 16 17 years
it's it's changed so dramatically my
first apartment in New York City where
I'll say let's let's say my second
apartment because it's more dramatic was
a top floor downtown Brooklyn One Stop
in downtown Brooklyn top floor of a
building floor through 15-foot high
ceiling central air
um the elevator came into the kitchen
brand new kitchen washer dryer how much
12.50 a month
and what is it now I don't know about
six grand Seven Grand easy I mean it's
crazy the apartment was not supposed
1400 square feet I had a drum set in
there it was crazy we had a ping pong
table
it's so they've uh I went to where I
grew up I went to Ada Street and showed
my wife and the baby
those people would melt if they were
there when I was growing up there's like
a [__] girls it's like beautiful it's
beautiful 88th Street it's like you
gotta see it went over there they have
like people drinking coffee 80th and
what Broadway between 88th and Broadway
is like you gotta be a [__] Rich too
like in the industry you gotta be
somebody's boss's boss to live up there
it's crazy they're really set up there's
one of the most expensive areas in the
world the best in the world yeah I love
it I love the upper stand up New York is
it you set up New York ah it's been 15
years yeah I still do that club they're
a cool Club it's been 15 years but you
know we were talking about a I left in
85 and cocaine was wide open smoking
joints and clubs is wide open in those
days the Colombians were taking
cigarettes taking out the tobacco and
putting Coke in the front and lighting
it up so it went through a nicotine and
it was like work like a filter
I went back in 94.
and me a buddy of my stinky and two
girls when I
and I went to the bathroom to do a bump
took the guy knocked on the door and
he's like you can't we can we don't do
that
and I was like are you serious this is
New York City he's like we don't do that
here yeah and I remember a time before
that I went up to the Upper West Side I
was a Yankee and I was 30 something I
was doing comedy and I think I went to
stand up New York to do one of the open
mics or something like then yeah and
then I walked up
I remember walking into a place like on
maybe 84th Street and it was all these
people drinking water bro hahaha
and [__] giggling and [__] I'm Gonna
Give You people would have seen what
this ball was like 20 years ago you
wouldn't have been hard it was the
[__] Westies that were in there yeah
before Irish due during that collecting
Vig and yelling there was Irish music on
yeah and now it's all these [__]
Gentile phases in there from College
Washington Square Park bro
I used to go there and see Chappelle as
a kid I didn't even know what stand-up
was I didn't know it was Dave Chappelle
I didn't know it was the other [__]
dude I had no idea when I saw Miami Vice
I said that's a dude from Washington
Square Park and when I looked them up I
had no idea I used to go up there with
bonehead I used to have a friend
bonehead that means stinky used to work
for him and he'd give us 50 bucks a
piece to pick up a toilet
go to the store and pick up cigarettes
and beer for him [__] like that but the
day started we would go do it the toilet
or do some Plumbing work and then we'd
go
to that [__] place that sells chili
and two beers or something mixed all
these ale houses it's still there tell
me that's still there where's that at
right Washington Square Park right there
or some type of beer place I don't even
know if it's Charlie's weak me and
stinky would go there we'd order a beer
we were we were [__] 17.
they didn't prove you then yeah we'd
order a beer they'd bring us chili the
beer and he would go to the park have
heroin Valiums yeah and weed for us
in those days you get eight tens eight
ten milligram Valiums with the v in it
for ten dollars
and he would walk back while we were
eating he'd go into the bathroom at this
place and he'd do a little do a little
blast just to keep him alive till eight
o'clock and then eight he'd go to
[__] zoomyville
and we did that twice a week yeah I
loved walking around Washington Square
Park that's how I said to you yeah when
I heard David Lee Roth got arrested
there I go that's the end Ari said at
Yankee games people got arrested the
Yankee games for smoking weed yeah I
remember going to a Yankee game
and people were smoking crack
there was crack files
93. there was something I got upset with
a guy smoking crack the other day
because I was walking down the stairs
with my kid and it's like I live in
Harlem and I look like where I live in
Harlem is pretty gentrified it's fairly
nice what street I live on one I mean I
live I live off of the the 116th and uh
like seventh eighth Avenue that area how
far are you from La Marquetta
uh just like a 12 minute walk under like
right on 170 yeah we're at 116th yeah
it's still there still there oh yeah
when you make Santeria I use you know
what's funny I always used to gonna that
I might have said this last time because
I think you mentioned that the last time
because that building that went down uh
was right there and I I lived a block or
like a half a block down from that
building that just blew up in Harlem
um so I used to live just a block away
from the the market right there
yeah so I have no culture I can't say
the market
yeah can you say it no I want to hear
you say it well Marquette my dad yeah
somebody can say it lighter than me I
love no I love my dad to death but he
still he calls Chipotle Chipotle
Chipotle Chipotle I tell them every time
I'm like Dad it's Chipotle that's a new
level of white he's like it's hey look
look here's the truth right like white
people see me as being like Latino oh
you look Spanish no I know yeah my son
looks Spanish my son looks you know he's
the same like complexion as me but he's
only because I'm half Italian Irish and
my son's only technically a quarter
Hispanic but he looks just like a
[__] little Puerto Rican man okay
great white person here because I had
shitty like really curly hair
and then his [__] now it's just gone
now it's [__] over see that's that's
where you see you think I'm young but
that's where it comes in
gotta pay I'd do somewhere you guys
[__] no you got great hair Charlie
you're losing it it's going down because
I puff it back the middle has puffed out
it's like a cake you don't use enough
flour did you ever see the cake on
Little Rascals when they [__] made
the cake no
click onto Little Rascals the cake these
[__] need to get a dress for
their mom
so they made a cake yeah and everybody
had to pay five dollars to get in there
to eat the cake wait do you see what
they put in the [__] cake
I don't know the juice
this is one of the best episodes of all
time that we're going to talk about what
we were talking about when you came just
I forgot about this yeah I don't
remember what it was the other day let
me get another star of death though I
feel like you guys are not respecting me
right now no we love you to death I feel
like you guys are not respecting I can't
well you know what you're gonna take a
whatever home so you're okay watch this
watch this [__]
look at stymie and [__]
[Music]
that's Petey the America's first pit
bull
[Music]
thank you
one of them is
all seems very racist I don't know why
oh this that's why Cosby bought him the
rapist and he took all the racist [__]
out of it other people put the racist
[__] back on
[Music]
as long as I tell you [__]
watch this
that's
[__] racist
the episode is this kid his mom gets
beat up by a husband and [__] and the
dad's a douchebag
so she wants a dress for her birthday so
these guys plan is to make a cake and
sell it and get the profits
to make a [__] dress
but they don't know what they're doing
they're just putting a bunch of [__] in
here yeah sugar and speed it up a little
bit Lee and I'll show you this let's see
where you're at go up a little bit
all right now that they're setting up
the party
and they start throwing things into the
cake that's a little weird you know it's
funny that uh did you watch that um
stranger things show
all right do you watch it Lee uh my
girlfriend has but I haven't okay so by
the way the cast a big part of the cast
is like these little kids they're like
you know uh 10 year old kids right and
apparently they they shopped it around
to a bunch of networks and they wouldn't
sign it because it was kids and they
said nobody's gonna get on board with uh
like a kid's ensemble cast
so it's kind of funny I was like you
don't really see shows that are about
little kids like who the [__] is
watching this just like pedophiles but
no this was 1930 1925
they played these children was this for
children I don't know they played was it
for adults or children I have no [__]
idea when I was a kid they were black
and white and we'd watch them you know
as when I was eight and nine I watched
them and I'm like what the [__] speed
this up a little bit and now they're
putting shoes in the [__] cake see
the cake is starting to trembulate now
watch this they [__] blow them look
at this [__] this is real stuff yeah
this isn't even special effects
look put that on louder did they let
this little black kid almost let himself
look at the cake issue well listen to it
foreign
[Music]
listen to the [__] noises
I haven't seen this in years I don't
even know why I thought about this
[Applause]
this is like if this wasn't like why
would this look at the cake
oh my God it's a big one
[Music]
so the middle of that cake that's my
hair dude you see how yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
looks like they didn't pay these actors
they just no they forcedure rob they
made them do sex acts this is 1925.
those people are [__] terrible this
is the first black market all all people
were horrible horrible horrible these
kids were this is all Races yeah these
kids came out years later they were all
out Keys they're missing an eye I'm sure
they tried to kill themselves they were
like [__] [__]
sad it was [__] sad that was with the
uh the Eddie Murphy sketch was about
right it was about buckwheat as an adult
was it yeah I think that's what it was
about right
look at these [__] yeah
would you ever let your uh your kid act
no me neither no I don't like what they
get faced with yeah because people
because my kid's cute as [__] my kid's a
[__] cute little boy oh no when I
when she was born the agent called me
because we set up an account for her we
should get him in movies and [__] yeah
I saw how they picked up that kitten
Sons of Anarchy they put him in a truck
they made the truck roll over
you for scale listen man I I did five
movies with kids do you think they make
the babies do their own stunts baby
[__] stunt doubles you could turn
this awfully I did five movies with kids
there was six situations that I saw with
kids that I did not like in movies I did
five movies with kids
and like I always say I saw this
Audition one time with a plate it was
raining out and it was [__] mobbed
and the you know people were [__]
getting rain down outside but there's
his mom and her little girl and she had
20 headshots spread around the floor and
20 people could have stood there
but in her in the mom's head that was
more important her little friends were
looking at these pictures
I don't want my daughter around those
people that their kids
are connected with directors and [__]
like that you know yeah in my house
we're real connected with my daughter
we're not into Hollywood stuff I don't
go to premieres I don't I try to avoid
as much of that Hollywood stuff as I can
well also like I think the reason it's
just in general for the most part like
entertainment and wanting to be an
Entertainer comes from some sort of
attention and I'm hoping my kid doesn't
grow up with that need because we've
given them that you know listen man look
at the final product of a six out of ten
of those kids that act yeah look at the
final product you know there's a
nightmare this this is this if I could
talk to my daughter and say listen these
people want to use you for a show for
two years you take that money and put it
for college
but know that you're going to college no
matter what happens know that you have
to go to college
and she's that strong yeah I would
consider it but I don't want her
mingling with those kids
I don't want to mingling with prize you
know there's just a bunch of kids that
walk around just saying that's my dad I
don't need that in my life I want you to
have your own [__] identity right do
you know what I'm saying it's real
important that you have your own [__]
identity this new generation they can't
handle it I've seen Sean Lennon's son
what does Sean Lennon do since his dad
died by the way it's the anniversary of
John Lennon today uh rest in peace
[__] that album was [__] great
maybe we'll close with some John Lennon
also uh Dimebag Darrell Dimebag Darrell
that's right dumb back I played uh I
played Cowboys and hell out of [__]
respect you know I was talking to
somebody's mom a friend of mine's wife
and he was telling me how bad the drug
problem is and like Malibu High
because those people got [__] I'm
sure yes my parents are out drinking
they leave the pills in the [__]
locker room the kids take them to school
you know it just I see it here this is
North Hollywood this is a shitty area
yeah and I've been to the Y swimming
with my daughter and there's been
couples that
they're watching that kid swim with the
nanny in the pool right that's unheard
of even my mom who was a [__]
alcoholic jumped in pools with me and
jumped in the ocean with me you know
it's beyond me you're gonna pay for that
later on yeah that's why like my kid you
know he literally he's never had like a
nanny never had uh you know like uh I
mean we got babies yeah I got a babysit
comes in Monday and Friday you know my
wife out but we don't even use her
anymore yeah we thought we raise our cat
and I have I have a buddy of mine I want
to say who it is but uh he was like uh
he's got money and he's like he's like
ah dude he's gotta he had a kid like
maybe two years after I did but this is
when he had like a newborn and he was
like uh he was like yeah dude yeah man
so you know it's [__] tough but he
was like you know I love dude I'm you
know raising this kid you know it's just
you know really really Hands-On I asked
him his schedule he was like you know so
I wake up at uh you know 6 30 with her
and then uh the babysitter comes at
eight or the nanny comes at eight I go
back to sleep and I'm like [__] hours
yeah an hour and a half are you [__]
crazy and then when the kids when the
chick's blowing people at the [__]
prom yeah that's when they'll come to
you [__] I shouldn't have that
babysitter I should have sat there when
I'm watching a cartoon or played with
blocks or something like that my phone
don't start ringing from business until
9 30. yeah I have mercy when I'm home
and listen man I'm no [__] best daddy
yeah I'm not here you know this is just
common sense type [__] I didn't have to
[__] read a book you when you talk to
somebody you know they're [__] broken
and the more you talk to them they start
talking to my mom or dad you know what
I'm saying my world it's Mom I don't
remember my [__] Dad we're all a
little [__] broken somewhere I think
it has to be weird just to have the
option to say oh well maybe I'll I'll do
a couple commercials I'll pay for
college like
no one it was the the most anyone had
was like the job I had like a CVS or
like that's the problem with the cities
in LA and New York and it's like kids
grow up fast and they also grow up I'm
in the entertainment industry so it's
like being around that it's going to be
very enticing and that's something I'm
gonna have to deal with you know in
reality it's like you're right I'm
talking about my kid being three of them
people put their kids at two and three
years old in commercials and you go like
you're not even giving them a chance
you're kind of you're entrenching them
in that World when they don't have any
choice and I think it's a weird you
almost you need to have something in you
to want to get in this world so let them
figure out if they have that in in them
it's just kind of very strange to me
that they could ever have a baby be in a
[__] movie what are you doing with
your baby
bro last night I'm sitting there stoned
to the gills I get off the phone with
Lee
and I noticed that there's a show on
about scientology I'm with Leah Remini
have you watched it
um
and she interviews different people who
abandoned ship and uh and all this [__]
and blah blah blah blah blah blah but
there's this one guy and she's talking
to him and the guy's crying because he
left and his family stayed in there
well you know what though you put them
in there
do you know what I'm saying listen man
I don't like people
I was very fortunate growing up nobody
ever took me down a dark Street
okay but there's a lot of people out
there that live their life to take
people down dark streets bro
and you get into a cult
you want to get into a cult that's your
[__] business bro yeah you can't put
your kid in there with these [__]
five yeah you can't do it you want to
join a call and go to buy it whatever
Jonestown and drink the [__] lemonade
that's fine but I think most people it's
not guys that are in the industry it's
people that have always wanted to be in
the industry that could never do it it's
that stage mom [__] or they want it they
want to look like Harris if they're
their kids that is Pistol Pete's dead
that's that's terrible no no so so I
think that's why you know like I know
what it's like I mean I haven't had a
[__] easy route in this industry so
it's like I know what rejection's like
that's [__] it sucks I wouldn't wish
this like if if I would have known back
then when I first started how tough the
industry is and how difficult it is to
make a real living here and then you
know to [__] make it as a comedian
dude I might have you know I might have
picked a different path at this point
it's just too late brother in today's
world it's tough to do [__] anything
yeah in today's economy in today's world
right now in America it's tough to do
[__] anything right now if you're a
plumber's Apprentice right now you got
out of high school how many [__]
options do you have what are you looking
for a pack I mean I want to tap this out
there's no way to tap it out tap it on
the floor there in today's America
if you're a kid and you don't want to
join the service
and you like construction and you want
to join a [__] Union how much work do
you think there is in the Union
you'll work steady for nine months
then the job shuts down
and to some people it's it's bad but for
you learning a trade it's even [__]
worse yeah you know how hard it is to
learn a trade in this country right now
remember 20 years ago you could walk up
to a construction saying go hey man I'm
a big guy
can I learned how to lay brick I'm gonna
go have you ever hadied before no I
haven't I learned how to be a hottie
we'll talk about laying brick yeah after
a year when you become the best hottie
out of five of them
the guy would go okay once your work is
done come on over I'll teach you how to
lay brick yeah and after five years now
you know how to lay break now you're on
a line you went from starting at nine
bucks or whatever it is now to 16 17 18
an hour and after five more years you
can start your own [__] business
that's an apprenticeship that doesn't
exist no more in this country because
right now we just hire immigrants yeah
instead of laborers for Laborers we just
hire immigrants I'm sorry I have to say
that word whether they're Russian like
Trump did or or Mexicans or Guatemala in
Jersey they're all years ago they were
Irish yeah 20 years ago immigrants does
sound like a uh like a nasty word but
it's not it's just a word it's the truth
they hire people it doesn't sound like
it doesn't it sound like you're like
saying something like that like
immigrants but it's just it's this just
anybody that's not from this country
that comes here is an immigrant well
here's my question is it they're hiring
immigrants because they're cheaper or is
it is that part of it but it's also
those are the people who are applying
for the jobs like see that's the
question I don't know that I haven't
figured out okay how many kids do you
talk to today that's at 18. you know
unless your dad's in the trades and he
takes you in the Summers and he teaches
you
you know how much work is for this kid
if he wants to learn a trade
that's what I always want like right now
there's three big construction projects
that we do in the Coliseum they're doing
the soccer stadium and they're redoing
some Village down there or some [__] you
know
I uh was thinking about that today how
much laborer work is there on that are
they doing [__] up labor where they
say they're paying the labor 16 000 now
but they bring non-union workers and pay
them eight dollars flat and they swallow
the rest of the money yeah I mean how
many of those are print in their
Apprentice programs I wonder how many I
haven't looked it up but tonight I will
how many apprenticeship programs now
there are
I know there was a uh I know this isn't
specifically yeah in the trades in the
trades but there was I I I did a course
and they had a I could have gone to a
trade school a vocational school they
still have that and when I grow up uh
but I I know that there's people who
make
a lot of money like I know it's kind of
a Hot Topic right now but people in oil
make the people who are out there
drilling are millionaires there's like
Millions I want to have my child aspire
to be an oil tycoon oh listen it all
starts by being an engineer right
no what would you want your little girl
to be if you could choose a career for
her to be what would it be
three careers three three that's a good
number either you don't have no kids
right no no but you're going to one day
you're gonna [__] drop seed in a
chick oh geez hopefully not for a while
either a lawyer a doctor
or some social feel where she feels
she's really helping people
yeah you know there's some people that
put on this Earth brother really help
people I don't give a [__] if they make
20 000 a year yeah I know a girl years
ago that was 40 something she lived like
an artist in a [__] one bedroom
office you know on top of a bar but
she's like I get to help [__]
minorities every day yeah you know
there's some people are doing that so
for me for her to have a good life she
needs to do that she needs to be a
[__] doctor God knows how much
college is going to cost in 20 [__]
years you know that's a big fear for us
in 16 years how much is a college going
to [__] cost at that time at that
time are you gonna really encourage your
daughter to go to college dog times
change I think in 10 years college is
going to be irrelevant I agree I'm not
in college is going to be around if my
kid really wants to see what's going on
now so I'm watching what happened with
him I'm watching the questions we had a
conversation a few years ago that I went
home
blown away yeah you know uh by him so I
don't think it's going to be relevant he
doesn't interrupt you no no please not
at all I well I'm gonna I'm good well
I'm not gonna encourage my kid to go to
college if he wants to go like I'm not
gonna be one of these parents going like
oh you got to think about college you
gotta It's gotta it's gonna be something
that he really wants to do in general
dude I tell you right now in life I have
so many friends I most of my friends
that have college degrees most of them
the vast majority of them aren't using
their degree no not at all vast majority
that's what I'm saying it's like two
that are and then some of the teachers
they're teachers right and then some of
them that dad's paying and that job is
it's not great I mean to be honest with
you teaching jobs just aren't really
great fifty percent of those people
their parents paid and the other fifty
they're lugging the [__] course yeah
I'm not saying nothing bad about your
parents you guys we split it but we
split it right but that's a crazy thing
that's a loaded thing to say they say
that college is going to be irrelevant
irrelevant irrelevant okay but then what
are you gonna do because now even people
are irrelevant yeah Donald's jobs that
you need to have a college degree
but no who the [__] is aspiring to be at
a college or a McDonald's job that's why
when people say you gotta raise the
minimum wage I'm like why are we [__]
battling for these people that have no
aspirations I'm sorry just [__] do
who wants to have minimum wage it's like
two percent of the people in the country
are make minimum wage why like you
should your thought process shouldn't be
like I want to make minimum wage
the thought process should be I want to
go go beyond that the people that are
making minimum wage should be should be
they're kids they're teenagers
disabilities we don't know about
somebody went through a traumatic
experience a divorce a debt maybe they
just want to get a job and be half a
[__] maybe serve hamburgers you know
what I'm saying McDonald's makes a lot
of [__] money every year the same as
all these other people you're making
nine bucks and now I'm asking you to pay
me six [__] more and raise the
[__] national average yeah I mean you
see what it costs to be a human being I
don't even call I'm listen I didn't say
the cost of Life did I I said what it
cost to be a human being
none of us could afford being a human
being anymore yeah you know what's a
human being we got the best soap we got
the best shampoo we got the best rug
cleaner we got the best jackets we all
try to cut Corners somewhere brother
right when we get to Beverly Hills we'll
get to Beverly Hills but for right now
we're all cutting Corners somewhere if
not this office would be on top of a
condo and then have [__] right now
fan of us and [__] and we write them on
the theater of the mind for the audio
listeners that's what's exactly what's
happening what's happening there's [__]
is everywhere right now the American
cost of living and what an American is
making I tell you what breaks my heart
right now I know this
thousands of people that want to go home
for their families yeah go look at those
plane tickets
go see what it would set you back just
to get on a plane without gifts right
without gifts just the cab the two cabs
and the thing to surprise your family
it's 700 [__] dollars
that's a lot of money when you're making
400 a [__] week my friend 500 a
[__] week right I I don't know I'm
not mad at you Louis but like we no you
are Lee I see it in your face I'm
furious but I don't necessarily think
that and I know you weren't making a
blanket statement but for uh the minimum
wage I met I've worked a lot of minimum
wage jobs in high school and college
and there's a lot of people who just
like
like just because you were fine no I'm
fine now but I worked minimum wage I
worked at KFC I know one of the best
experiences in my entire life was
working at KFC absolutely dude I'm
telling you right now you just it was a
one of my first jobs that I had for a
while that I had to really be
responsible with it wasn't [__]
supposed to be the be all under I wasn't
supposed to live my life off of that job
but there are people that are willing to
do that work I just go like it's a very
small percentage of people that make
minimum wage we should be focusing on
how can we how can we push people to be
doing jobs and can and and educating
people and getting people to do things
that are Beyond just the bare minimum
[__] jobs that are out there it's
not like the good jobs are paying
minimum wage you know what I'm saying
what is the national minimum wage right
now at this point in our lives I don't
know it's a national minimum wage what
is it right now well I just I've never
it's just so far I can tough out there
guys
do it stand up there's no seven
twenty all right so 7 25 times 40 times
40. that's two that's 300 a [__] week
my friend yeah that sucks that's 1200 a
month what's your rent
um
yeah I wouldn't work for minimum wage no
I know but I wouldn't do it think about
how many people are very very small
percentage of people 25 an hour I did
not know I thought it was nine dollars
an hour no that's crazy and even 360
don't do nothing for us
1300 a month you ain't doing dick with
13.00 I just nobody's [__] get I work
I do stand-up comedy I've worked so
[__] hard nobody's giving me a
handout there's no minimums in my life
I know but people make their decisions
people give them a decision people make
a decision to work at McDonald's but
people have make a decision to work at
McDonald's because things aren't going
too well if comedy wasn't going that
great for you you work at McDonald's
part-time and do comedy part-time
but I I wouldn't I would do something
else and I'm not saying everybody
I would never work for minimum wage as
an adult I've been going to McDonald's
lately with my daughter
once after soccer yeah my wife and I
take it to McDonald's I get the quarter
pound I don't eat the fries
you run right through the [__]
bathroom that's how you know McDonald's
is terrible I'm not even a call and I
gotta [__] everything has the same
flavor like the milkshake the french
fries the burgers there's a McDonald's
like film The last time we went on even
eating nothing and it was dying to eat a
Big Mac a new Big Mac don't look bad
they shrunk and listen I don't [__]
know there's a new Big Mac there's three
new Big Macs I wouldn't touch them I
don't know they broke them down I was
reading it but I was high we should get
do they deliver with that no we're not
getting McDonald's delivered here that's
disgusting can we do Big Macs you take
the [__] stink out of this office for
a year I can't come in here I'm gonna
have to get those carpet people well we
talk about McDonald's and I was looking
at the people who work at McDonald's
right here I know
this one here I don't want to say the
name
they weren't destitute people
they were a couple college kids the
manager you know there's a great story
that I think I told Lee that the manager
the guy that created My Name Is Earl
yeah Greg Garcia won the strike when he
was doing My Name Is Earl the brightest
track he got a job
on the McDonald's on Laurel Canyon the
Creator yeah and he started from the
bottom washing bathrooms and [__] and
after three months they offered him like
that that's the plot of coming to
America what are you talking about you
went over there was a Louie Anderson's
character this is from 2007 2008 to
write a strike he went into that
McDonald's right on Radford
and got a job at CBS right there by
where his friends are
he didn't think his friends were going
to see him and he worked and yeah he
mopped floors and they said they
promoted him to french fries and the
grill then they got the money and they
came to him and then they go would you
consider being like if you worked this
way up to the [__] head of uh WMA he
[__] took the checks gave him back to
him he goes this is who I am I just
wanted to do this as an experience oh
well you know and I remember talking to
him last night he was it was so weird
that I was in there and doing this
because she tried sometimes and then
what we thought about it just got the
McDonald's job for a few weeks but then
quitting in an awesome way stinking legs
back no I'm not gonna say none I'm never
gonna come back you want you to check
not really give it the [__] uh
McDonald Land give it to Ronald McDonald
she's [__] jerk off in the fries the
last couple years since I travel and I
see what America looks like and how
different sometimes you got to do what
the [__] you got to do man I think I
think the people [__] you gotta do it's
just a reality they don't even it's not
that they're not ambitious because a lot
of the most of them because they make
300 a week have to work two jobs I don't
think that many people are look up the
amount of people in this country that
are making uh minimum wage I'm trying to
find it but this chart's really small I
think that we are talking about a very
smart percentage of people Maybe I'm
Wrong
maybe dude can we get callers if call in
right now
866-522 Church
866-522 church and we want to know
we'll find out I can't they always
charge it okay all right
about 1.7 million earned below the
federal wage minimum
um I don't even hear the sirens but it
sounds like Joey just left to go fight
cops
all right what I think it's
okay so there's 3.3 percent of the
hourly paid workers
um
so yeah okay so it's three throwing
three percent of the population
3.3 yeah
that's still a lot of people though
that's what how many people in the
public give me the number of people
because here's the thing
it's 3.3 percent of the population makes
minimum wage okay 78.2 okay in 2015 78.2
million workers aged 16 and older in the
United States were paid at hourly rates
representing 58.5 of all wages and
salary workers
among those paid by the hour 870 000
earned exactly the federal minimum wage
and the 1.7 had wages below the federal
minimum wage you know what so that's not
that's fine 78 million not that many
people
it's bad out there you said something
very interesting you worked at Kentucky
Fried Chicken how old were you I was uh
16 to like a year and a half two years
if your son comes to you when he's 15
and goes dad I want to climb two years I
want a Camaro what are you going to say
to them you're gonna go go work in
Kentucky Fried Chicken whatever you make
put away I'll match it
is that that
listen man you always want the best for
your children you uh
you sit there and you go for some reason
I'm very cautious about this you know
when my mom died there was nothing I
thought there was millions and there was
nothing yeah my mom was still married so
he got no will he gets first dabs that's
crazy I uh the same thing my parents are
both dead zero like I hear about people
getting an inheritance and I'm like
inheritance I got [__] crazy I lost so
I just lost you always want to prepare I
watch people get in Harrison I'm like oh
you gained something like I'm kind of
jealous in a weird way when people
family members die but you always want
to prepare for your child you always go
you know what let me prepare for her
yeah in case I drop dead doing [__]
Jiu Jitsu or doing bong hits the stars
at death with these two [__] Savages
and then you start thinking about
realities okay what do you want your
child to do I always think about can I
take Mercy to 148th Street and drop her
off at [__] Mr Gomez's house for the
weekend so she could stay with the sun
could I do this I trust you yeah
people could they do what we were doing
20 years ago walk down the Riverside
Drive home to the bridge walk back
around Broadway walk up to 150th Street
go to block parties could you would you
trust your child to do that at 10 like I
did right I don't know anymore no I'm
not 10. I was doing it at [__] six no
six six I was walking around walking the
Riverside Drive Crossing across Broadway
I used to live on uh in up in uh
Washington High School there's [__]
like literally children like two
three-year-old kids out there with no
parents like an older brother will be
there like but that older brother is
like seven or eight but I'm talking
about two in the morning three in the
morning and you go you're like all right
dude well this is I'm saying right now
those kids if they do if they don't end
up selling drugs and being criminals if
they don't then that is a [__]
miracle good for that guy who gets out
of that because it's nearly impossible
if that's what you're growing up in just
the [__] Hood there's no way there's
no how is that up there now it's bad
still dude up in the Heights there's
little pockets that are nice but here's
the thing the further you get away from
centralized Manhattan like whatever
Borough it is it's really it's it's it's
okay so I get off the bus from Jersey on
the George Washington Bridge can I still
get weed and Coke right in that area is
that on the street as much too because
they clean up the streets a lot you'd
have to like you look like a [__] cop
there's no way you look you look like
you walked right off alone order and
you'd be trying to buy drugs with me
there's no way you wouldn't get it I
wouldn't get it Lee wouldn't get it nope
you'd have to be like a Puerto Rican kid
or a Dominican kid who you'd have to
know somebody you'd have to live in that
area and have a guy that you know but
all they have to see is you go to the
store two or three days in a row
um you know you buy blunt wraps you know
they see you you say what's up a few
times you'll be fine after like a few
days but there's nothing on the streets
like when I left there in the 80s there
is but there's like there's Hood guys
that are like hustling the not even just
in the hood like you'll go time school
you'll be more likely to go down to like
West 4th Street by the comedy seller or
like you know um you know Union Square
area if you walk around a square at
night or the weekend they'll be like
black dudes or Puerto Rican dudes will
walk around like oh you want weed you
want Coke you can get it from those guys
but you got to kind of like just get
lucky and pass one of those dudes but
there's not really dudes nobody
Dependable if you live in the hood yes
there's guys that are hanging out in
[__] stairwells that you can go to
but you got to live there you can't just
walk up by yourself there's no way
it's changed a lot yeah I could buy
I could get off 178th Street walk three
blocks in the direction
30 years ago 20 years ago and and buy a
gun
that's crazy Coke heroin weed
I didn't know meth or anything like that
to get a gun the first time this all
right so you walk off
back in those days this is how easier
this is how crazy it was in those days
you walked off
uh uh Port Authority walked onto
Broadway and he uh you know I'm gonna
[__] up the streets you get off 178 176.
yeah you walk two blocks and they used
to be on the corner there was a Cuban
place
and I would go in there and sit down you
know talk to people like just talk more
time
whatever order and eat and then from
there I would walk around the block to
that Park there's a park right there I'm
not good with names this is I bought a
few guns there in 85.
and then I bought and sold a few guns
there 93. so it was like you could just
like walk up and it was almost like a
walk up almost like a pawn shop but I
forgot they're playing basketball out
there and it used to be a handball court
and I always tell people somebody told
me this 30 years ago like when you want
to buy a gun go to a handball court
because they're all like felons out
there playing handball it's not like you
know every once in a while cops get out
there and play handball but besides that
it's a shitty it's a shitty sport it's a
shitty sport but that's what you learn
to play in prison so you talk [__] you
want to Hype it is that is that where a
hamburger got popular is prison I don't
know I don't know the [__] history I
haven't bought dog I'm just telling you
that [__] you know but I used to go
there in the mid 80s
because the the word on the street was
if you had a car and you wanted to get
rid of it
you got off like you were going to the
West Side Highway and then you got off
and right under there used to be a
bridge and it was a street that oval dog
in those days over here is pull up your
car there so that street was connected
to that Park the people who ran that
Park ran that street I mean walk home
from the basketball court they would
take the cars that was their last
mission of the day they would take the
cars and sell it you would just drop
your car off come back tomorrow your car
was guaranteed gone in the Bronx chopped
up by [__] three immigrants on its
way to [__] Saudi Arabia yeah that's
the truth that's the truth root
so it was all connected so somebody told
me yeah just go to the park if you want
to buy a piece
and one day I went over another 22 for
like 55 bucks what it must have shot 80
people this gun was good this is good it
was wow what was the one movie where
they that's how they described it
they're like how many bodies are on the
guy yeah yeah that's the listen it's
like juice or one of those if you buy a
gun on the street you want it to be
[__] heavy duty you want this is the
gun that killed Kennedy
I thought the less the less bodies on it
the more valuable the gum was because
then the less the cops are looking for
this well the cops are looking for this
gun so they catch it they're going to
pin you with 18 burners so you better
get it and shoot the [__] quick
kill somebody the only thing that's good
about this gun is that don't miss this
is not [__] ghetto people are though
that like you bought it for 50 bucks
right you shoot somebody you're gonna
probably sell it back to them for 25
bucks so why would you just get rid of
it why even waste your time throw it
into the [__] River I shoot somebody
with a gun I do something bad like I did
something once with a gun that was brand
new 600 bucks for this gun I threw it
away yeah you got it done
couldn't you just throw gun how many
guns you think are just in the [__]
oh my God oh my God right under the
bridge people just shot somebody and
they're driving over they just throw it
you go right where the bridge ends you
get a steak you got a bunch of divers to
just drop they'll pick up machine guns
[__] grenades [__] submarines
a body pops up in the Huts in every
[__] day yeah some something from his
body has to decompose into the water
yeah the fungi toenail the [__]
armpit rest something happened that that
water jump into the water because I grew
up in Rockland County New York oh [__]
yeah 914. [__] yeah dude [__] it was 845
now but back then yeah it is Puerto
Ricans would come down and jump into the
uh off the penny Bridge
we used to [__] literally jump off
that bridge when the only when the high
tide were coming because when the low
tide was coming you'll break your
[__] legs but when the high tide was
in there was a certain time of day you
would jump off the penny bridge but then
they also had like [__] wooden planks
so people would like shred up their legs
jumping off this thing but that's the
type of [__] boredom you had when you
were 12 in the suburbs of New York you
that you you're looking for crazy [__]
to do so it's almost a weird balance
because no matter where you raise your
kid whether it's the city or suburbs you
have to worry about your kid [__]
either becoming a drug addict or [__]
killing themselves because of boredom
well here's the beauty of this
and this is not yeah years ago Rogan
said to me got stuck on an apple one day
because he saw these people jumping up
and down and he goes you know they were
Cuban and he goes it made me think of
you and put a smile on my face because I
got to see what you really about he goes
there was eight of them and they were
having a [__] parade at the terminal
yeah like they were taking over the
terminal had music on they were dancing
in the 80s it's it's not a joke but in
the 80s when you grow up in the suburbs
of New York uh
Brooklyn the Bronx Queens you know the
Hudson river is like [__] South Beach
you know what I'm saying so and if even
if you watch
Kaplan there's a scene where
two black black couple yell at Stallone
they go hey man you [__] are
racist and [__] and that was that's
every weekend
because to them they don't want to go
another Jersey Shore they don't want to
go to nice beach today and Puerto Ricans
were the best
they would pull up like with a [__]
four-door car right
with tinted windows and I was in the
four doors that are open and 19 people
walk out but then the trunk would pop
open and out of that trunk dog they
pulled out two coolers a pig four conga
drums it was on and they would take that
little corner they would clean the
[__] Grill off and they'd go fishing
and oh yeah we go fishing are you crazy
you might have seen Lucy's family I grew
up fishing in the Hudson that's not even
weird and take fishes out that [__] is
the worst that's worse than Katrina fish
do we go crabbing in the Hudson oh we go
fishing yeah what do you think [__]
how many bodies are we just talking
about you got metal poisoning
That's why my hair one time gums bleed
me Mike ask Gleason is dude Johnny Lopez
that was crazy used to shoot around he
used to shoot cats and dogs on they but
I mean his whole family was crazy the
mother was in cancer and they used to
sell her pills her pain pills they were
55 a piece they were called terminal I
mean they're just a crazy family nice
people though I like them he took his
fish
he took me and Devo fishing one time to
Hudson River and we're out there we got
a couple six eight packs we're drinking
we're smoking no drugs and we're fishing
and also Devo pulls out this [__]
fish
like this eel yeah they've got tons of
eels in the Hudson River yeah I did and
you catch yells in your line all the
time you let him go oh he slit the heart
out and we ate it we ate the [__]
heart like their asses
Americans I'll tell you this much I
don't even know what it is we've at
least nailed the not eating weird parts
of animals because in every other
culture they [__] eat everything dude
it's disgusting that heart lit like oh
I ate rabbit once and it [__] me up a
little bit dude all that [__] [__] me
up lamb all that can I tell you why
because it's so I had a little leg right
it was like nothing frog too same thing
these little dainty things you're like
dude you're killing a [__] animal it
doesn't matter that it's smaller I get
that you get more meat I mean you're
taking the life of this animal right for
almost nothing for like a bite of meat
we're not primitive it's not like we're
just [__] catching something there's
no reason people want to say they ate
frog whatever somebody comes at me and
goes oh my God we had frog for dinner I
want to back candy in the mouth because
yeah who would eat a [__] frog I did
it in Puerto Rico I didn't pour I did
rabbit and frog because I wanted to try
it yeah one time you my [__] wife
one of those people it was lizards not
lizards my wife's family eats those
[__] thin squirrels that's crazy
they're from Tennessee and they get
square on barbecue it with barbecue
sauce yeah they eat the legs and [__]
whatever to each his own I'm like you
know I like brain bro when I was a kid
stop [__] with the mic I know one of
the best things my wife my mom used to
make when I was like Puerto Ricans
cooker
those little fish [__] smelly fish
you're a fish that's grinded down there
you deep fry it with flour and they get
all they come back a little Frito but my
mom used to make those things but bakala
she used to make
fritas
so with some animals brains and she
would take the shield off [__] soak
him an egg flour them slice them thin
and deep fry those [__] with
some lemon on it when I was a kid I
watched them this [__] yeah delicious
you ate them make believe I didn't even
know what the [__] they were but she
would cook them so well you don't know
what they were oh no I knew what they
were she would slice them so thin and
cook them that both sides would just
like
a half inch apart so you never even
tasted the brain you just tasted the
crispy stuff I ate a [__] spicy tuna
roll when I was 11 and I almost puked
that was like the most exotic thing that
I ever had in my entire Sushi now yeah I
love it oh please all right I [__]
love it at least
sushi with this [__] I went to Sushi
I went to Sushi last night with Bruce
Buffer he told us to go to that place
Katana right next to The Comedy Store
how much you dropped 282 dude it was
[__] crazy here's we were bringing
him and we told them that before we
should have told them afterwards dude he
[__] he killed you dude he killed us
the voice of the UFC [__] beat us
down what'd you drop in there like 400
some dollars oh I wasn't even drinking
oh no you can't drink in there I made
the mistake of taking somebody there
once on business and they ordered three
little steak sticks that are delicious
that's that's what it was those things
are like 20 a piece I know we're sitting
yeah forget it I'm watching Bruce Buffer
just [__] eat four of them
we were at the store starving because
you want sushi guy Joe I got 8 000 in my
pocket what do I give a [__] I'm not
gonna lie to you I thought we were gonna
paint that together sandwich yeah I had
enough for a sandwich and an iced tea
he's like no I want a little dog before
we go in there I got eight dollars
because I don't give a [__] come on
I looked at the menu
they were like 20 bucks for three right
how much for three sticks uh no not it's
more than that it was I don't know what
it was it was it was I think they were
like nine dollars each other twelve
dollars each stick first [__] time
you ordered three at three table three
dishes of them yeah my heart just sunk
I'm like I hope I don't get half this
checked yeah and at least I'm ordering
sake's and soups and I'm looking at this
and I'm cleaning 12s 18. it's just crazy
it's just every everything
and I'm getting more and more
embarrassed no no no I don't like that
[__] at all listen down the corner is a
great little Sushi's Pub Bruce Buffer
it's 12.99
there's literally one like across the
street oh my God and seven hell isn't it
Hollywood Sushi or something like that
oh my God
I love eating good but there's some
places you just avoid you know when I
say to you let's go out to dinner let's
go out to dinner once you start ordering
those 12 cocktails my leg starts tapping
yeah you know after I count the second
one I'm like what the [__] are we going
for here this is just 80 and Cocktails
I've never seen seen that because I
don't drink yeah I don't like my friend
he's got a sister that they got her and
her husband boyfriend go out every night
they go on Facebook they're always
drinking a pale ale from this place yeah
and she just had to take another
part-time job and I go that's because
they're drinking they they cannot be
surviving on what they're making
drinking every night it's pretty crazy
dude being a comedian it was easy
because you're not paying for [__] but
how people could go out and be an
alcoholic and go out to bars every night
is beyond me especially there's still
dive bars in the city correctly you're
going to four dollars Dives I mean very
few when I started drinking in New York
City I was 20 years old we started going
to a place called The Village Idiot on
14th Street and 9th Avenue and that
place was [__] garbage like it stunk
like you walked in and it'd smell the
pizza place down the corner from there
or across the street Goodfellas pizzas
that's still there um but this place was
a [__] like the type of place where
all the bartenders were just [__] in
bar in broads but they were like trashy
they weren't even hot they were just
[__] like [__] chicks and and uh it
was like peanut shells all over the
floor but it was it was five dollars and
fifty cents for a Bud Ice pitcher
a picture and then it was a two dollar
shots of like well whiskey so we would
get [__] and not literally 20 you
walk in you're annihilated dude just
[__] annihilated and you and we would
just get into fights we would [__]
chicks in the bathroom it was like the
craziest time
um so yeah I guess that but I don't know
any place that's like that in New York
City where it's cheap like legitimately
cheap they used to be a place called
Manhattan Honda is that close to that
14th and I think it's 14th and 8th see
where Manhattan Honda is Lee if it's
still like the uh and I used to have a
friend that worked at Manhattan Honda so
he would tell me if you're ever in the
city come over and say hello we'll have
a cocktail and then I had a girlfriend
who lived across the street so it was
like steel like go see her and then I go
meet Corky and we'd walk down to this
bar that was where is it
all of your references about New York
are based off of where car dealerships
are this guy worked there so he
introduced me to a certain that part of
New York he knew all those bars and [__]
so one night me my buddy the Gearhead
who's now a Freeholder in North Bergen
and that guy I met him over there and we
went for a drink
and we go to this place on and how to be
I don't know if that's 11th and whatever
this is two blocks away either or and
it's like that bar shells on the floor
yeah a little stage a bartender who was
hooked on a crack just got out of rehab
she just picked up the shift because she
walked in here is with that movie Coyote
Ugly or the bar it's like it's like a
tourist trap but that's what it kind of
pretends to be okay this place was
really that this place was only packed
on the weekends and it was like a couple
like college students that were probably
doing heroin and [__] like that I'm in
there one night
and there's this black chick that you
could tell she sucked a thousand dicks
yeah but she's at the bar working at
chat she got half her titties out
and the black dude sits next to her and
that song comes on what your man got to
do with me I got him everything so I'm
not trying to Butcher and he just starts
yelling at it
and he's trying to work her at the bar
and she's saying no and that song was I
never forget this I'm on the other end
[__] up there's Pizza shells
everywhere some chicks getting you can't
go in the men's bathroom because some
shit's [__] in there yeah I was crazy
this place I don't know it that you
described something close to it
and then blow I remember is this this
guy kept saying what's your man got to
do with me
what your man got to do with me what
your man got to do with me I said [__] I
gotta get the [__] out of here yeah
what's your man got to do with me I miss
all that part of New York yeah it's it's
[__] it's hard now man especially
it's so funny because comedians in the
beginning there's no money at all like
at all it's nearly impossible to make
Eddie Money doing comedy in the
beginning so it's like you're in the
tough the best place to do it is New
York City or L.A but to be honest like I
think New York City to begin and to
learn how to do comedy I think that's
that's one of the best there's more
places there's more places you know so
Freedom yeah yeah so I think like it's
just kind of a weird ironic thing that
it's such an expensive city to live in
just the cost of living is so expensive
but then there's no money for the first
few years so you're just struggling you
can't breathe for the first few years
doing comedy in New York well here's the
deal she got a really [__] one I went
to New York for nine months in 93.
and I was rocking and rolling Within two
or three weeks what is rocking and
rolling me
I was doing five sets a week
there were 13 comics in the room yeah
you know but for where I had come from
from Colorado it was Dick oh yeah that
yeah
and if all you care about is stage time
and fun yeah that's it dude oh yeah but
I always found a way to make a pretty
good living yeah and I wasn't selling
drugs were like apart how are you making
money when you were in New York City
I got hooked up a friend of mine hooked
me up
at the time it was called Virginia yeah
he's so bad I want to hear this damn
good take your time
yes sir what's up [__] oh my
goodness first off I'd like to thank CSO
TV for uh putting my special on that I
don't know if you guys know it we were
the number one uh all-time Premiere
special and this is thanks to you guys
man you guys uh helped me out with this
I really needed this with CSO and
you know everybody's happy you guys made
my [__] year so thank you very much
for being very loyal you know I love you
guys with all my heart
and all that [__] so that that's worked
out well I got him in there let me give
us some shout outs real quick
first off I want to shout out again to
the dead Squad and church families for
really coming together from Bobby Sharon
and Crystal right now having a they're
listening right now reviewing party
to Kyle Wallace to Dustin and Oasis to
Jason uh uh I don't [__] know
Silverback Surfer David Nolasco Ratliff
307.
Seco Uki spooky
Tracy the church family Kern Michael who
came to three [__] shows you know
everybody who supported the podcast I
love you [__] with all my art
man thank you very much for everything
you've done for us man that's all I
wanted to tell you right now I wanted to
take that
and tell you that you made my [__]
year this is the best Christmas present
I've ever had so
thank you very much I'm [__] up too
Lee don't feel too bad no I'm I'm I'm
alone I'm what what what what what is it
[__] sucker I'm not super [__] up
ready for another one let's do it all
right
this will put us at what 16 16
[__] 100 kilometers of death
catch it what are you looking away for
almost every day since I was uh almost
18 years old listen this hits you a
different way yeah and if you're not
used to these if you eat 600 and walk
out of here yeah oh my God you're a
legend you're a [__] Legend no shut
up oh please you're a legend you walk
out of here with 600. I'll walk out with
a thousand I will do it no you won't
nice I swear to God tomorrow I'll get a
call that they gotta call the hospital
no this ridiculous anxiety attacks yeah
bro
see I've taken the amount of you I'm
just a drug no I know is it not the
teacher does it not affect affect you
the same way that smoking it affects you
no no not even close I don't know the
science behind it but I'm telling you
right now it's just THC Now call Joe
Rogan he'll tell you an hour
it turns to something else in your liver
and it becomes hallucinogenic and you
[__] ask oh and Benjamin Ash Red Band
when he called the ambulance twice no
yeah he had to pull over on the one how
many how many how many do you have to
pull off this was years ago when it
first started the craze nobody really
knew nobody really knew what exactly it
did to you so you can pop one
interesting question
for some no it's not interesting but
interesting before
it's funny because ever since
the last the last week I've really been
thinking about 1993 in my life yeah that
was a really deciding factor in my life
to why I got here
that was the first decision Big Year
well what happened was
I got divorced I was broke I was out of
options and I had to move back to New
York
and I really wanted to do com like I was
doing comedy about a year and a half but
part time
I was doing it like here and there to
pick up a [__] [__] or whatever I
really I had no juice because I remember
my first year of doing comedy I
pretended that I didn't want to do
comedy I was just hosting shows and I
was like I don't really know I wasn't
even hosting I was doing three minutes
here two minutes here yeah I was
inconsistent I wouldn't write blah blah
blah when I went to New York I went out
at night
but immediately when I went to New York
I got a job dropping off packages for uh
it's amazing like how much hustle there
was back then there was a job dropping
off packages hello packages to
businesses for like a t I forgot
Virginia and something yeah it was like
an ATT division at that time
I had I had that job for like two or
three months and the kid goes you know
what we're gonna switch it to Brooklyn I
didn't want to go to Brooklyn every day
like they were going to move zones I was
with them towards the end of New Jersey
and all over Manhattan and up in
Manhattan there was three or four of us
they paid us 400 a week and all we had
to do was drop off 20 packages bro like
it wasn't hard at all
and then when I'm backstage is that
still out in New York yeah all those
things are kind of dying now because of
the internet the internet so but those
things but it's out there yeah but those
things had jobs all catered to Comedians
and comedians yeah yeah selling it
making Insurance appointments what are
you [__] kidding me to give you 10 an
hour and 25 an appointment and 35 more
if they sell the [__] you know stupid
[__] yeah but you're making a living dog
yeah but you got to focus on it
you gotta [__] focus on it I was like
a 17 year old dude they had a [__] it
was like a whole like 30 [__]
telemarketers in a room just calling up
old people trying to get them to uh like
refinancing their mortgages yeah our
whole goal and I have no idea it was the
shittiest business was to get their
social security number you get this
social security number you got 12 bucks
you got everything else you got eight
bucks so we were literally just we were
destroying these old people's lives and
they had teenagers doing it we didn't
give a [__] dude because you get that 12
every time twelve dollars so if you were
good I was a monster I was I just knew
numbers dude there's a ratio boom play
the ratios keep on going keep on going
keep on going keep on going and I was
just just dialing like a [__] it
was an awesome job but I know that I
ruined probably three or four hundred
people's lives completely oh people
probably a few suicides in there
it's like a family is just losing it all
I don't know what they did with the
social security numbers it wasn't good
no no because before this before the
internet so nobody could look it up dude
there was no like there was the Better
Business Bureau at the time like like
there was internet at this time but it
was like you'd have to like go to the
Better Business Bureau website and look
up to see if somebody took a claim now
there's [__] Yelp for everything so
you could easily find out if somebody's
Shady in terms of business but back then
you could do [__] people were just
crushing it oh it's amazing I sit here
sometimes look you were talking about
lighters before and stealing stupid [__]
for a long time when I was in my real
loser fade of life my mentality was if
you're that stupid to leave it there I'm
gonna steal it yeah which is a horrible
mentality when somebody learns a lesson
yeah I think it's if you get away with
it I figured there was a movie where
they talked about that it was a great
see in the movie but I was like if you
can get away with it you can't that's
your payment you know what I'm saying
which I kind of under there's like a uh
you know the you know an honor honor an
honor and thievery type of mentality
which I kind of I always like in a movie
like I always kind of root for the
thieves and like you know that always
kind of plays to me in a weird way I
grew up [__] like I tell you my mom
would my mom would teach me to to steal
[__] testers when we go to Baxter's
Pharmacy and she's like yeah I go and
like take me to like the perfume testers
and if they catch you tell them it's my
birthday and just start crying
if there's embedded in my head when I
was like six and seven years old that's
like some crazy [__] no my mom didn't
like buying nothing unless it was stolen
it's crazy like unless somebody brought
us something stolen from a truck yeah I
don't want nothing I don't want nothing
it's funny that uh
just gonna [__] tell you something I
forgot what the [__] it was God damn it
it's funny that you said that before I I
you know you just had these wild
fantasies as a father and what you want
for your child you know yeah
and I sit here sometimes ago you know I
said that statement Lee because first of
all
I'm gonna talk her into it
like I would talk to your son into Lee
when he's 17 and he comes to me and goes
Uncle Joe you think I should be on the
[__] radio like you and my dad I'm
like oh [__] no
it was a different time then you know
there was hookers and [__] no I'm gonna
go you know maybe go to college but not
right now I want you to learn something
first I want you to learn about people I
want you to learn about human nature and
I think the best thing
teach somebody about that is belly to
belly sales yeah belly sales makes you
realize this [__] is out there but
I'm going out to my car for my license
I'll be right back what happened to that
guy he didn't say that are you that
stupid are you that [__] moronic no
but he said don't believe nobody and
then you really learn about society and
after a year come back to me in a year
that you keep one job steady for one
year you don't give a [__] you're just
gonna grind it out yeah there's nothing
better out there it's just a job you're
gonna live at home you're going to eat
at home I'll even give you a little
[__] extra spent I'll make your car
payment do this for a year yeah and I
help you out you can Bank your money and
I'll give you 50 I'm saying like just so
they learn what's out there before
listen man most people and even me
as [__] slick as I thought I was
when I was going to college
once you decide you got to do something
with your life it's [__] scary we've
had this conversation before Lee four
years is over [__] four years is over
the diploma you got to become a Phi Beta
Kappa you got your dick sucked now you
gotta go find the [__] job it's
[__] scary out there I almost feel
like it's starting over you go find a
job now you got to go through now you
have to learn how to find a job you
learn how to find a job then learn the
ends you got yourself from the bottom of
that bottom again I think he's like 10
years later you've wasted your whole
life on some [__] job you hate you're
you're now you're 28 to 30 years old you
wasted your whole life you're like holy
[__] dude I [__] hate this and this
is what I have to do that's what sucks
about the school model and that [__]
thing I think like I would encourage my
kid to be an entrepreneur I would
encourage my kid to [__] you know not
necessarily like you know I I want him
to like come to me here's the thing
right he's in preschool right now and
this is what I love about his preschool
it's like a play-based preschool and
they have all these stations set up when
he walks in and the idea is he goes to
what he wants to do and then the
teachers come around to these different
stations with the kids and they kind of
as the kids are playing uh they kind of
inject the lessons about math and
reading and the different things that
they can do around what the kids are
kind of interested in so it's it's a
pretty Progressive kind of cool way of
teaching these little kids and I think
that's kind of a microcosm for for kind
of how I want my kid to like look at
life and how he how he does things and
chooses to do things in life he's like
do what you want to do you'll figure out
how to make the money around it it's an
old stupid [__] saying you know do
what you love when the money will follow
yeah but it's legitimately a real thing
and I kind of believe that you know I
believe it too I believe it in terms of
the sale it takes a lot of courage to
believe it
it takes a lot of courage to sell it to
people but
if you dive into something and you
wholeheartedly die but like when I dove
into stand-up dog I don't I bought it I
bought the whole flag I knew well I got
a job at a comedy club and ask the
comics questions and even though they
all said you don't want to do this you
don't want to do that I knew that what
they were avoiding and that's why
they're somewhere else now yeah I was
never scared of work or hard work yeah I
knew that for four years you got to live
like a nomad what does that mean you
can't have much that's it can't have
much well that's a it's like comedy
College it's comedy you go out there you
know there's very few people you know
there's like two or three that make any
money before that like you know like
it's it's not even exaggeration it's
very it just doesn't happen so you're
paying your dues but that's what I was
saying before about being in New York
because that's a [__] tough place to
pay your dues LA's great dude being a
dude's out here you [__] it's
beautiful weather rents cheap yeah but
everywhere you're gonna pay your dudes
and stuff I paid my dues in Denver in
Seattle
you know I'm in the beginning you're
just an open Miker both those places
have uh legal weed now which is kind of
interesting [__] crazy so back then I
still know what it's that's kind of
funny I saw it in Denver and I was an
open Micah
and then after three or four months
you're like [__] this job yeah you're
like [__] this job I want to be a
comedian and then you go into this life
of death
it just becomes zero I was living off my
credit cards and then once they want to
ride Mr Gomez I was [__] yeah and I
started hustling I learned how to put
together hustles like one of the hustles
that you said to me what did you do in
Jersey League take notes [__] my buddy
hashway came to me
and he goes
die
I'm gonna buy a car
you could use it
what I want you to do is pay me off the
car and buy that for 200 you could use
it around Jersey don't take it into the
city I'm gonna get insurance for here
but it's your car pretty much he goes I
want you to become partners with me on
my breakfast
he goes think about it let me know what
you think and I have some money he goes
I got people coming in but I really want
to build my delivery service what do you
think
and I thought about it for a week and I
went back I was doing comedy
really into the comedy scene I wasn't
getting nowhere though I was just
bombing in New York every night you paid
three dollars to give you a drink ticket
yeah but in those people some places you
had to bring people in those days yeah
some places as long as you brought the
three dollars and you got the drink
ticket they didn't give a [__] of your
boy and that's what I do I just zipped
into places did six minutes bombed and
would ask myself what the [__] am I
doing like I said the one thing that's
cool now is in New York there's a whole
Open Mic Community where there's no food
nothing like that you just go up and
they support that yeah no that's I knew
it would grow at this time it was still
a lot of clubs a lot of action seven
nights a week that was [__] 10 open
mics in New York and all the Five
Barrels it's it's tremendous Jersey I
would go to this [__] St Rocco's play
I mean it was just it was just great you
know but I wasn't getting nowhere I was
spinning my [__] Wheels it was the
beginning you know so I said I gotta
figure out a way how to make a [__]
living too in those days it was 25 a
gram for a cut and 35 for uncut it's
called right on 178th Street weed was 10
five dollars still I wasn't doing bad
with that either because all I had to do
was go over the bridge for people and
[__] like that
so I figured out a way to get I I
wouldn't I wanted to hashway one then a
little dog I need for you to pay me
eight bucks an hour to make phone calls
and I called all the I went in the
Yellow Pages and I got all the
businesses in the area
I got in the car and I would any place
that was a mile away Miley shops
anything and I went in and going let me
get you faxed them I'm gonna fax your
menu every day and every day I get that
[__] 9 30. and I'd start faxing
numbers
it's just press it with one sheet you
just press the numbers and I'd be there
for 30 minutes and talk next thing you
know orders started coming in he went
from three deliveries a day to ten yeah
to 15 to 25 what's the soup of the day
it was my own [__] Department you
know I was walking out of that one time
bro I was in shock when I did the math
now
I was making eighty dollars a day in
tips that's 400. plus another [__]
you know he was giving me another two or
three hundred a week yeah I was making 2
800 delivering [__] sandwiches though
that's great and still wasn't paying my
bills and I was [__] doing open mics
and I was probably driving a limo I had
eight jobs at one time when I was in New
York when I was an open mic I mean
that's just I was I had a big nut
a big addiction yeah and I had to pay
rent I had no car I had to cut I had the
ash waste car and then I got a job
driving limos because the guy gave me a
[__] limo it was tough man yeah it's
tough out there I can't imagine now
where they've cut some of the hustles
you know now what are you gonna do if
you just want to sell weed see an open
Mica could sell weed well I think the
problem now is like people also that
they get to keep on going on because
everyone's online everyone's
interconnected everyone knows what's
going on so people aren't like dropping
off as much like and then also in New
York now it's nothing like that it's not
like 10 of mics now literally New York
City there's like without even
exaggeration there's probably 200 shows
going on tonight if you count everything
between all the five boroughs easily now
the comedy cell is packed to stand this
package Comics there's two rooms they
got the village on a comedy self the
village underground which is packed huge
Room comedy seller village underground
is packed uh the stand is packed
um and then there's just a bunch of
clubs in New York Times Gotham's always
go to your comedy club is that Al Martin
still yeah I'm Orange in New York no no
he sold the New York he sold it okay
he's Broadway still and he's got another
one right by the Comedy Cellar called
Greenwich Village so I mean there's
there's like there's like 15 clubs but
then there's all of the other there's
independent rooms there's like another
like 30 like cool like independent bar
shows that are like hip and like you
know the industry comes to and then
there's a bunch of shitty open mics and
and craziness but yeah it's great dude
New York's New York's a thriving place
but it's also a [__] [__] ton of
comics that aren't doing anything and
it's like there's no barrier of entries
so it's just kind of like the
competition just keeps on rolling in you
know me I'd rather right now if I was no
Michael
I go to Michigan I go to Chicago
develop an actress and then come and
have MP I go to Portland I go to Seattle
there's so many markets that you could
go in you're still going to struggle but
it's going to be a little easier
struggle you're going to live with three
dudes in a two-bedroom you might have to
live on a couch or under the stairway
but you know you're going to be a bar
back three nights a week and also movie
theater when you come to New York City
or L.A and I started in New York City
and you know I know dude you're [__]
starting off being somebody where
everyone has their eyes on you as you're
not good at comedy you're not gonna be
good for a few years so if you work for
a few years outside of New York get good
yeah and then come there you have you
know 15 minutes that you can impress
people with you're going to be in a good
position well Brody went to New York and
when he had 20 minutes 15 years ago yeah
you know that was good he was developing
in Seattle Mitch Hedberg already had an
hour or two when he moved to New York
yeah you know that's one thing you know
here's the thing if you're good you'll
make an impression right away yeah
people want using people want good
comedy it's it's like you know and
there's a lot of [__] Comics you kind of
stand out when you're good in New York
what about just as a person like not as
a comedian is it still worth it to live
in New York City as a person yeah
because like it's always been what you
want to do everyone's a [__] rock
star in New York the attitude in New
York City is if a celebrity walks past
you on the street just the Gen if you
work in a [__] bank or the library
your attitude is like yeah who gives a
[__] I don't give a [__] because the the
average Banker thinks that they're the
[__] rock star of their Bank you know
what I'm saying so there's like almost
like you ain't [__] type of attitude in
New York city so you almost have to kind
of have that if you want to go there
because I don't think anybody's going to
New York City to kind of be happy and
can content with not making it quote
unquote in whatever industry you're
going into it's too it's too high of a
risk why wouldn't you just move to the
suburbs and do something else you know
okay I see what you're saying I mean I
don't really think I'm that Cutthroat
but it's always been a dream of mine to
live in New York City so I mean I think
eventually at some point
not really no
I mean I'm in the industry but I'm not I
don't think I wanted to stand up
um
but I don't know I've ever since I was a
kid visiting New York from Boston it's
just
I love Boston and it's like it's it's my
home but New York's a different feeling
new and as soon as you get as soon I
remember getting because I always used
to take those buses and they would drive
through Harlem and as soon as you get
into Harlem it's it's it's a different
feeling somebody starts screaming
because black people are approaching the
bus oh it's terrifying
but um I had allusion to Grand you'll
move my family in New York I always
liked the idea of walking around the
upper west side holding hands and
walking to the school like I did and
doing spots then I got the reality I
couldn't afford to live on the upper
west side so I have to live in [__]
middle New Jersey somewhere which I
wouldn't know you could afford to live
in there [__] no [__] but I can't know
and I wouldn't do it not probably no
yeah you could I don't listen man I
think you did believe me I'm not moving
into a [__] apartment no that's the
thing you're not gonna [__] have like
I'm sure what you have out here is
[__] no no no no no I can't go
backwards but you could afford for in
reality right you got a daughter and a
wife is that it yeah I need two but no
no no
I need three bedrooms all together okay
for a three bedroom apartment upwards
that were used to 88th and Broadway yeah
look it up no it won't be there no it'll
be cheaper than that I don't know for
six thousand seven thousand yeah that's
perfect stress level to put yourself
under when you're my age you can find
you can find it free you can find it for
five if you really luck now probably six
seven listen man I wouldn't want to put
myself I wouldn't want to start the
month minus seven for a [__]
apartment yeah it's expensive with a rat
downstairs
in the winter I can't do it I'm thinking
in terms of a one bedroom which is like
yeah yeah no no
check that price yeah
wait what would you do in New York
though you just want to do like uh I'm
not I'm not going anywhere anytime soon
I'm just saying one day yeah eventually
it would like it just seems like a place
the place to be like I I honestly
thought I'm looking for these stats no
it's okay
um I honestly thought when I was going
to college that I would end up in New
York I didn't think I'd be in LA
but I I got a I got a job offer so yeah
yeah dude I didn't [__] dude I didn't
[__] like New York at all when I
first uh moved there really yeah I would
visit with my friends like once in a
while when I was like in my teenage
years and it was just too much dude
there's too much [__] craziness and
too much noise but then you start to
realize that that's only like Times
Square like that's not like oh yeah I
hate times what a [__] you know
little like cool areas you go to Chelsea
or like you know Hell's Kitchen or like
you know Lower East Side there's like
cool like Pockets that aren't like
chaotic like that but yeah dude it's
[__] I don't know man I I
New York City is a [__] I don't I
don't know if I want to raise my kid for
the rest of my life in New York city so
oh yeah like that's the thing I don't
think you could I mean granted it's
these are just my opinions uh without
having a kid but I don't know if you
could raise a kid in the city so that's
why if I did it it would be before I had
kids that's why I'm no you I do raise a
kid in the city we currently live in
live in the city with a kid is it is it
harder it's way hard I mean dude that's
it right now like not driving like do
here's the thing when I live in New York
City with a child you got to leave a
half an hour early for everything that
you would just do alone just [__]
walk into he walks and you can't [__]
drag him you gotta [__] like my mom I
probably would have just dragged me and
[__] grab me by my leg and drag me
down the street with the caveman but you
can't do that you know so you literally
got to walk your [__] kid and he's
now in an age where he just is too big
for me to put him on my shoulders these
[__] almost four he's big too
um so yeah it's a dude it's a lot harder
man you know it's also like kind of
[__] dirtier like you know I got my
hand I want my kid's hand on a [__]
guard rail on this New York City subway
I just thought about the money
I told him about the winter time I told
her about the nut I would have to make
I thought about the drive to Kennedy
Airport in Newark or whatever
and I thought about my life here that
you don't have to move Lee out at first
to do the podcast find him in a [__]
apartment
you know you know they would be living
in [__] oh he would love it on a
couch in Coney Island yeah he wouldn't
give a [__] I would have to live on a
couch these prices but oh ridiculous and
you look at what nut you have to make
and you have to be realistic I'm not
dirty [__] oh my God is 32 you could
sell me a boat about anything and I
would think about it and go now I know
what that nut is I know what that nut is
I know what that nut is at the beginning
and I know what the [__] cabs are
there's something about
um
there's something about like the I
almost feel like mentally I really mean
this and then you know this with sales
too so like let's say you got a sales
goal right whatever the sales goal was
for the month right just typically you
know if they made the sales goal let's
say five more units that month or the
next month you hit it you hit the goal
you know what I'm saying so if then if
the nut needs to be bigger I just think
it's with a sales mentality you would
just make it bigger or not I agree with
you I would do that I've been doing that
all my life so you were just that's not
the problem I don't think it would
change your life
I'm paying seven G's for a [__]
apartment is it seven years all right so
three G's a month that could be going
into an account for my daughter okay so
there's downtown Midtown
West Side Upper West Side okay and you
want a three bedroom
yeah a walk up starts at 6 000. oh walk
up and an elevator doorman starts it's
72 Grand just to pay rent hey grand for
an elevator you want an elevator doorman
dude you don't want to [__] walk up
no that's what I'm saying no no I dream
about walking up
that's what I do every [__] gang Ole
Miss I walk around going you know what
I'm gonna move out of here cause there's
no [__] steps I want to walk up four
flights of [__] steps I see steps I
get anxiety
and healthy for some people I don't like
stairs I see stairs it ruins my
appetizers [__] that [__] I gotta in the
summertime it's fun obviously oh dude
it's it's [__] 98 Degrees it's humid
as [__] there's dirt in the air you
can't breathe you gotta walk up Subway
steps sometimes when you find you hit a
certain thing where you're like deep in
Brooklyn and you realize you got to walk
up like four flights of stairs on the
subway in the summer it's [__] awful
dude and then you gotta do it with a
baby now imagine you got a
three-year-old that you gotta carry up
these [__] stairs
it's craziness
no thank you 53. eight G's a month so
when I look at something now I have to
look at it for the family how's this
affect the family I have friends that
have kids and they've put themselves in
Holes
and and look at them and I go how can
you put yourself in this hole Yeah to be
cool
you don't have to have like a motorcycle
or something what are you [__] crazy
yeah every movement I make
is around my family has to work out for
them of course you know I tell people
people get pissed off being on my
schedule I got a crazy thing about
myself my agent called me last night
he said don't these people offered you
this you should definitely think I said
what week is it the game of the week ago
it's three weeks a month
listen
they know what I got I got a family
I got a podcast but I got mouth
those are all my jobs I told you a year
ago
it's two weeks a month I don't care what
you throw at me I don't give a [__]
you know when I'm in town here on
Fridays and Saturdays I'm with them bro
yeah I don't really like this week I'm
not doing comedy I do comedy an extra I
had to start from scratch anyway the
special came out it's over so
you know when I any move I make I gotta
think about my family
I know you were friends and with type
but let me move my man I gotta think
about them how does it affect them you
know these people call you for all this
[__] and they get pissed at you and
you're like you don't understand that
doesn't benefit them
I can't take them with me the [__] I
just got a call for some Comedy Festival
in Louisiana and the guy called me back
he's like I don't understand why you
can't do it I go the money's [__]
terrible and I can see if I brought my
family down with me but I'm losing
you're taking me away from my family for
a third of what I make again I gotta
stay at home with them I don't want to
be that comic that goes on the road
every week and then has a stroke in
[__] Connecticut one week and now I
can't go on the road no more we have
lives man I don't want to be that guy I
saw what that does to people every week
to be on the road [__] you my friend
[__] you I need to reduce my batteries I
need to be with my family yeah I like
taking my daughter to school and picking
her up and you know going to lunch with
my wife to some shitty taco place or
yeah going to see a movie I don't want
my life to be when I was 30 yeah I could
do all that [__] I could do did you see
a rival by the way arrival no I didn't
say nothing oh
great [__] movie but you got a kid
dude it's the worst
it's brutal dude you got a [__]
daughter oh my God you're gonna see a
rival Joey do you cry movies ever all
the time okay you're gonna [__] I mean
and I mean this Joey what kind of movie
is it it's uh it's like a oh Will Smith
no no it's a Sci-Fi it's like it's
[__] well first of all stop right
there I don't do something let me tell
you Joey it's got like 98 of Rotten
Tomatoes
cherry tomatoes come on
listen to me that would never happen in
my world you listen to me it's a great
movie everyone loves it it's gonna win
every [__] award this year
I'm not everybody but now listen to me
it's not it's not it's not your typical
[__] sci-fi movie okay I won't go to
it at all
can you talk can you turn the trailer on
can you watch it sure
are you watching the trailer on me okay
let's see here listen to me it's a good
movie but it will [__] it will break
your heart sure would you watch it on TV
if it came out no
what's the best movie Whatever wins best
movie of the year I haven't seen Avatar
there's a lot of movies think so that's
stupid this isn't like that dude there's
a lot of movies or like movies of the
year that I could tell just by looking
at nothing this isn't sci-fi like that
too I'm telling you right now watch the
trailer you gotta watch it it's [__]
cool oh he's not gonna watch this go
ahead put it on yeah sure whatever boy
you know what did you say it no I I I I
I recognize the trailer
I keep forgetting he knows me well you
know he's seen people pitch me through
that purple he has he knows that there's
people waiting for me at movie theaters
oh my gosh I'm sorry for giggling listen
to me I'll tell you I'll meet you yeah
we'll go tomorrow
I'll meet you there at four o'clock wait
for me I'll be there
let me take it by me buy me a soda
[__] nachos
I set it up
all right here we go that's Amy Adams
that's the only reason why we go see
this movie so she's hot yeah I like them
yeah she's cute she's beautiful she's
Irish just how I like them red hair and
dirty I love white chicks dude I love
them is your wife white [__] yeah Irish
like this I [__] love it white chicks
are the best
okay so this doesn't look like sci-fi so
far what do you want where are they from
you'll be reporting to me but you'll be
working with him when you're in the show
that's what they call him the UFO all
right two out of three actors I like say
[Music]
it's a giant turd
who's being parted off in the Medevac
not everyone is wired for what you're
about to do
so what do they look like
you'll see soon enough
every 18 hours a doll opens up that's
where we go in
oh
she's the language specialist
and they're like they're communicating
with these aliens
which I don't know if it's over yeah I
just said the word aliens that's it no
we don't know what they are yet Joe it's
just a bird
I don't give a [__] if it's two birds
it's [__] Forest Whitaker in his eye
that's okay I see Forest Whitaker in
other movies
unlike martians it [__] what's his
name
four options have landed around the
world this is one of 12. I'm never going
to be able to speak their words got two
days figure something out
human
it's their language
you need to make sure it's great dude
I'm getting Goosebumps right now it's
really good it's good
killing me over here it's [__] great
I [__] took a 10 minute minute Gap
out of the podcast
yeah it looks good take this [__] off
warships and martians let me tell you
something you will [__] you will cry
you will cry your eyes out no he won't
because he's not gonna see it I'm not
gonna see it trust me oh my God my wife
would go see Give me a review
that was great anyway my wife likes
these movies I don't like I don't like
sci-fi either I hate it I like I don't
like drama I don't like sad movies no I
like all that [__] questions Dan Soder
do you know Dan no he's a [__] great
he bought me a ticket to see this movie
I didn't know I was like I don't I don't
want to see I didn't know what it was he
was like dude it's great everyone's
sitting Instagram I was like fine sad
[__] movie I don't like sad movies
I've dealt with sadness in my life so I
don't need to watch fake [__] sadness
it's so funny to me that people go and
watch it's the only cocoon
I don't remember it I remember when I
was a kid I don't remember people they
jumped in the pool yeah yeah that was
okay I didn't want to see that either
but that's a sad [__] sci-fi movie it
was a sad movie it's good when somebody
dies somebody gets shot in the head it
don't bother me much I like comedy I
don't like movies that are designed to
make you cry
well Rocky ain't designed to make you
cry cry like a [__] which one though
all of them no Rocky one because of
Rocky three Mr T no I don't think so
but I cried to all of them
Rocky I love you all that [__] makes me
go [__] anything with uh Godfather
got shot in the beginning I cried
anything about being a dad like that
[__] like now there's all the kids
movies too you know how many [__]
dads get killed in kids movies now good
dinosaur
[__] uh you know Lion King which is
good Sammy's mom gets killed you got to
prepare him they could come so you got
to sit him down and go listen I snorted
a couple ounces in my day ate some
badass I swam in the Hudson I had crabs
from the Hudson I hang out with Puerto
Rican people
most people live to their 74 most men I
might not make it there so number one
let's do the best we can
and number two I'm just letting you know
people disappear from time to time
you gotta let them know do you with your
daughter when a person dies in it
because I don't even know how to really
deal with it because his grandpa just
died is uh his mom's father and you know
she he doesn't really get it he's four
no they don't get it but in the movies
they kind of like you said oh his
Grandpa died
my dad died when I was that age when I
was four years old my wife but I don't
know my wife's father looks like [__]
Herman Munster
if my daughter if he dies and my
daughter had to go back and see him in
that box it would shock of her life she
didn't want to know what the [__] this
is oh yeah no no we didn't bring him
because she wouldn't know what the [__]
this is they don't understand that I
don't think I understood my dad's death
at three I don't think my mom took me
down there no no I didn't go to the
funeral my mom told me before I remember
my mom telling me I remember the blue
sheets on my grandma's bed she only
break Grandma's best she sat me down she
said oh you're dead your dad died he's
in heaven now she was crying and I
remembered not really feeling much you
know did you go to the wake no oh that's
what I'm saying yeah I didn't go to the
wake I mean my mom telling me he died
and I didn't really understand it for
about a year but I didn't go my mom
didn't take me to the wake up I see that
it's gonna [__] up of that yeah at
that age because you're you're so
sensitive to your programming them it's
like to deal with that type of [__] I
don't know you know one of the worst
things I ever did as a kid when I was
about 10 or 11 and you didn't say New
Jersey my mom had the ball
this little boy and girl got kidnapped
little boy and girl got kidnapped then
I'll miss her for five days and they
found both of them caught up dead
and I'll never forget that for some
reason or another I decided to go to the
wake
Jesus like I was just a young kid for no
reason I watched it on the news it
bothered me so much how old were you
maybe eight nine what and I walked I was
at McKinley so I no no I wasn't at
McKinley it was the summer of Catholic
school and I walked to Union City
I stood online
and I walked past you can't dress did
you dress like anything or you were just
[__] dressed like a little kid just
dressed like a little kid
I just something about those two kids
dying I felt like I was connected to at
that age I don't know why
I just didn't know why I saw it on the
news and I felt so [__] bad and after
that
I remember that I never talked to nobody
in a [__] car like when people pulled
up next to me I don't know what the [__]
you're talking about
it was really weird how these are the
things you fear for for your child man
you don't know how to break it down but
that was then you could [__] we were
walking around and I was in the suburbs
so I was in the city but even then the
suburbers were [__] up too there was
pedophiles out in the suburbs pedophiles
we talked about this
you know about this a couple weeks ago
yeah I mean we were [__] walking
around my mom I mean
from the time I was five on I mean four
or five on my sister was two years older
than me she kind of watched me a little
bit but we would just go out I mean we
would disappear for the whole day that's
it did your parents talk to you about
pedophilia when you were five or four
ever my dad was murdered when I was four
my mom my mom was pretty open with like
a lot of [__] crazy [__] like I was
like I knew what sex was my mom was like
you know it's almost like to a fault
like she I she didn't she [__] up she
was crying she was trying to like be
open about [__] and like teach her kids
my mom too she just [__] up she didn't
get her to do it the right way she the
the idea was right but she [__]
missed the target Lee you ready for
another star death star of death Lisa
yet Lisa yet Lisa yeah
um I I think now about the mistakes my
mom made that I don't want to make with
Mercy I don't want to tell him I'm not
going to tell my daughter I'm gonna
stand there forever alone I can hide it
yeah
however long the other day she came
running in the office
and I was trying to everything they
would send me notes for the special this
is about two weeks ago they wanted me to
cut the beginning I left the immediately
looked at it and I took it home and I I
we went home I went home the next day I
was trying to write the minutes and she
came in
and she goes Daddy
and I thought she was gonna catch and
she didn't catch it and she ran out she
goes mommy mommy Daddy's on the computer
I'm the computer
whatever the [__] she says and my wife
wanted Michael says pewter pewter the
pewter and then my daughter goes look
Mommy look and then I said some but she
never really caught it yeah and a couple
weeks ago at school
something happened when they asked her
is your dad funny and she goes nah and
they all laughed and they were like he
came in today and they said I said You
know guys don't [__] say no if they
asked me at my kids preschool because I
I wrote it on the thing that I'm a
comedian that's what your occupation was
I should just write radio because
serious exam
um but they were like oh would you want
to come in and do jokes with the kids I
was like lady do you know what the [__]
I do like and then she told me she
looked me up afterwards at the parent
teacher she was like she was like yeah
now we get it I said look I'll come I
know how to juggle and I'll like joke
around with the kids and you could tell
them that I work in like radio and stuff
like that we can maybe come in and they
can record their own radio show because
you know but my kid thinks I do
podcasting for work because I do a lot
of podcasting so you know he knows like
you know when I go out to my studio and
you know yeah he doesn't understand what
stand-up is you know and I tell I tell
ridiculous jokes like I [__] like my
kid you know he should never curse
around him no I try not to I really try
not to slip and he don't pick him up no
no she [__] he tells me if I cursed
it he's like no dad but then he catches
me but then he gets to [__] say it
because he knows what he's doing so I'll
say [__] and like he's like dad you
can't say [__] and then I'm like and I'm
like James you know you can't say he's
like yeah but you can't say that I'm
like oh no okay got me she hasn't got me
yet she's [__] got me yeah why
I love you so much
why
the last time you went here you [__]
me up because I left here
and I thought about somebody who was
really important to me growing up like
he was a big bridge
and we're trying to put it together you
know he's got the HIV yeah you know so
uh I remind you of a guy that has it bro
when he when he was 16 he didn't have
the him right all right but he was one
of the most solid dudes I haven't met he
was Cuban and French yeah his name was
Dede Quintero he's got a Brother Carlos
and deeney was a bridge like I think
about deity now like dog this guy they
used to call him Manchild he was
fighting men when he was 15. yeah and he
was a badass [__] yeah we got
into some [__] [__] when we were kids
you know I told his brother some of the
stories he was hey you know you guys are
doing that [__] I'm like [__] yeah we
were robbing a gas station 15 16. we had
it we thought we had to figure it out
right he had a devilish smile like you
but you know what my mom died he took
right to me and every day we go back to
his house his mom would feed me and [__]
they would give me the biggest piece of
chicken he would get mad as my mom why
does he get the big piece of chicken
because his mother died that's why all
right he's your [__] chicken and you
remind me a lot of them man I think
about Didi a lot now let me tell you how
deep he went
just to tell you this guy people women
would come up to me girls in high school
come up to me and go how do we get with
him yeah he was like a ladies man
you know we were friends till High
School I left in 83 we lost contact his
brother was wanted they were looking to
kill his [__] brother some gangsters
and right before I left they were
looking to kill me too not the same
people and I was in a shop right one of
those places like in [__] the other
end of Jersey and who do I see in the
hallway that's so funny shop right such
a [__] lawyer I grew up like things
everywhere yeah yeah I saw Carlos and I
go Carlos and he goes don't tell nobody
you saw me I go call us they're looking
for me through he started laughing
that's the last time I saw them
years later I go home and I go what
about the video like bro you better sit
down
and they go this [__]
because when we were kids we did a lot
of acid bro there was a lot of nights
that we just went straight like there
was no recovery we just did acid every
night we didn't ask it for a week
straight and we take two nights off and
then his brother would go out and we'd
wait for his brother we'd do a quaalude
and we'd drink a bottle of poop pop
vodka
and we wait for his brother to come home
we'd sit there and throw he'd give us a
line of coke we were 15 16 we're [__]
kids man you know
years later they told me he was the guy
that pulled up next to you in the car
and ask you what are you doing right now
on a bicycle with no shirt on
and he was just blowing guys in the
Hudson County parks
just somewhere the mental health came in
yeah he had mental health issues in his
family
shooting and all that stuff over the
years they just found them
if I'm 53 he's got to be 49.
they say that you know he looks good he
looks healthy for having that but he's
working at a
whatever the [__] you call it
Salvation Army loading trucks he lives
dead too yeah
he's putting it together you know what
I'm saying it's rough we grew up
together but his family was known for
having mental health issues yeah he was
the brother now when I talked to him
sometimes it's funny in conversation he
goes you know my memory is not that good
I got hit in the head with a pipe a few
years back and it [__] me up and when
he says that every time I laugh because
every time I see him he always says the
same [__] thing for me
thank you
Providence [__] Rhode Island
how you feel 600 milligrams I feel good
man your face is starting to change now
I'm telling you right eyeballs are ready
I think I can [__] Dance I'm telling
you right now don't dance don't no dance
no I'm not a good dancer no dancing but
I I'm done I think the the challenge is
there so 400 milligrams I walk out I'm a
legend 600 I'm what did you eat this
other one I ate the other one yeah I'm
at 600 600 you're a legend I'm a legend
all right let me know that I'm having a
lot of [__] respect here from me
brother good first off a lot of people
come in here crying there's a lot of
people I don't even say nothing to
because I know they won't eat nothing I
don't listen I don't want everybody to
eat it you know when you came in the
first time you came with a reputation so
I just wanted you to yeah loosen up you
came in a little you were a little you
know and this should have loosen you up
damn how you feeling look at Lee I think
this might be my record 1600 yeah we're
gonna go for two more hundred oh no two
more hundred two more hundred at this
point what's the at this point you know
what's the only difference the hospital
bed that you wake up tomorrow and
there's tubes in your arms you're like
Mr Syed do you know why you're here and
you're like
uh let me guess yeah I don't think my I
don't think my insurance cover is
marijuana OD
yeah smoke some of this oh cool man what
are you talking about oh my god oh yeah
we're going deep into the Mercury on the
way it's getting crazy baby
I'm gonna stick another star drink a
little water
I'm gonna set the record at 1800 Mr
Gomez here next time he comes on
we're doing two thousand
sure sure
what do you think of that
I think it's [__] phenomenal I'm
proud of you guys we don't [__] around
here I know I built these tolerance up I
built my own tolerance up I work hard I
don't want to be one bro I see these
[__] guys from California talking
[__] how much refill they smoke I don't
smoke no reefer when I show up with my
guns they melt what do you have in there
oh my God
I had to leave here and drive eight
miles and walk on the beach and meditate
what the [__] are you talking about
so I want [__] to know when
they come on here
there's a long lasting effect
you know the same two [__] just
[__] around here we're breaking it
we're going for 1800 tonight Lisa
swallow that champion Lee like this look
is that
[__] it leave it for the mouse
you got what you got nothing look at
this like that like a doctor and [__]
okay
okay Providence Rhode Island go see my
man Mr Gomez two shows Friday two shows
Saturday do me the [__] favor like
you went to see so and downloaded if
you're in the area go see him have a
good time bring him a [__] number if
you're abroad and you got a sore throat
suck his dick it usually goes away you
know what I'm saying My Girl My Girl's a
comic so she'll be there it's Christmas
time [__] 24 what is it look at
this poor kid look at this
hold on to the computer holding on
through his nose like I threw him in the
deep end
[__]
ing start off the floor we're gonna
split this no we're not yeah
I got it
please I think we should go three ways
what all right we'll do it three ways do
it three ways I'm ready to go eat the
star eat the star eat the star
s like just like that so we went 1800
plus tonight ladies and gentlemen it's
gonna be a deep night almost 600 people
what I don't have to sleep tomorrow I
don't have to get up so I'm getting
anxiety all I'm like I'll be breathing
heavy all [__] night and that's it
and that's that [__] products
wrote out of me I got no [__]
dates I got nothing till the 21st of the
Chinese restaurant can I promote a
couple other little bits sure all right
uh January 14th we'll get that it's
that's not even gonna work because it's
too far away okay by that time it's the
holidays drop them anyway
January 14th [__] that day January 6th I
went to Kaluka Casino shut the window
that was the wind though Detroit Hustler
Club Louis Gomez January 14th myself
Dave Smith special guest Joe list Legion
of skanks presents get your tickets
Detroit hustleclub.com
um that's gonna be crazy dude the
strippers there are [__] smoking hot
we're gonna have a really filthy dirty
show and it's gonna be crazy you're
crazy I like these strip club shows
they're pretty dope you're a bad
[__] I'm too old for those
things no I go in there I look like a
creepy old man you fit right in they
talked to me they asked me creepy
questions I don't do well on strip clubs
I'm not a strip club guy yeah
yeah I mean I don't here's why I went to
One Last Christmas by myself I ran it
and ran out can I tell you why I'm a
strip club guy and I'm good one okay
because I don't ever pay for lap dances
I don't give a [__] about that [__] no
you don't so I'll go in nobody they just
drive Corvette because nobody pays for
that I know I just go in and get him a
dollar and walk out I'm sure you do it
then he goes to the VIP and starts to
finger bang your [__] till it's [__]
bleeding today no I'm telling you I know
you're gonna hang out I don't spend
money no no
back there like J cool
and they all talk to you because you
know no they don't talk to me I'm just
saying the reason it's not a big deal
for me to go to a strip club all right
[__] off
no no you go to this strip clubs you're
disgusting young man and every once in a
while those [__] hypnotize you yeah I
got a lap dance uh Detroit House of
black man it was [__] and it's not
one you get three of them no I got one
you got three of them you don't have to
lie to nobody with family here let them
know that you're the Captain Kirk of the
Enterprise I go to a strip club you take
200 out of the ATM how much of that it's
20 let's do [__] 10 throw one in for
11. and if not let's do three give me a
hand job and suck my and drink to come
oh [__] and [__] we're good for
the other lap dances yeah you can have
it you can do the breakdown whatever you
want yeah oh you don't want to dance you
can lick my nuts and [__] and [__] uh
we'll call it Partners I don't give a
[__] I just can't do it yeah the last
time I went to a strip club I really
enjoyed myself was Blow Street in Canada
Toronto Canada it was filthy yeah I was
biting it yeah up in Montreal you're
allowed to play with the titties yeah no
it's filthy I like all that dirty [__]
but to sit down like a half a [__] and
look at your [__] I gotta pay eighty
dollars to [__] finger you forget
about it you know I'm not into that I'm
too old I walk at listen Last Christmas
I went to The Comedy Store on a Sunday
dog I went to an Amy ATM machine I took
out a deuce and I got off of Van Nuys I
made a u-turn I saw a strip club and I
saw a girl I walked in there was three
girls sitting there lonely as [__] I
couldn't believe it
last time I went to a strip club there
was 200 guys
and there'd be 16 girls dancing and
money would be getting through this
place was sad but all these three girls
were hot and I got to the car and the
one girl was like Joey Joey I just
watched you at the show we listened to
your podcast come in I said so what goes
on in here she gave me a menu I said
give me a dance I got another dance and
I just broke it down I said listen
what's the story you're gonna let me
smell that monkey what are we doing he
was I can't do that okay business is
shut down I thought it was like the old
days I could smell your titties and [__]
like that this is all far they dance
four feet away like I'm [__] easy
with div you know what I'm saying
[__] you you gonna give me the papers
Lee or I'm gonna sit here like a [__]
students for four hours I'm over here
waiting taking Hill through it on his
own but no you didn't ask me I gotta ask
you you're the [__] producer of the
show are you not the producer
are you not the manager yeah I have
right here all right then get it
together anyway
the picture World we're putting out a
new pair underwear isn't just fresh
you're stepping into a better day you
will walk into underwear and they're
[__] tremendous and you can feel your
whole day change you ever have that
that's what happens when you put on me
on these all right how the [__] do I
know because that's what I went to every
time I work out I wear me underneath why
because it keeps the moisture in because
of a fabric a material called modal
that's pronounced m-o-d-a-l
me on these focuses solely on producing
the most comfortable underwear you've
ever experienced period my friends at me
Andy sent me a pair a few pairs a while
back and now I can't imagine wearing
anything else now they sent me a
Christmas collection Santa Claus with
white balls on my balls [__]
tremendous all right for the price of
two cocktails me of these will deliver
you a new favorite pair underwear right
to your doorstep better day guaranteed
you're trying them on if they aren't the
most comfortable best feeling undies
you've ever had they'll refund you and
let you keep the first pair for free
including the price of the sweet Touch
of motor a special fabric that is best
in its class raw materials that are
scientifically proven to be three times
softer than [__] cotton I'm telling
you you know you wear the the white
underwear and listen this man these will
change your [__] life the Uber free
cozy undies are sold exclusively on the
me on these website where you enjoy free
shipping in the US and Kevin now because
of the holidays for a limited time
everyone in my audience gets 20 off
their first order but you have to go to
our special URL
meundies.com Joey again
meundies.com Joey with me on these
better day guarantee you have nothing to
lose especially around the holidays
worst case scenario you got a free
prayer underwear so don't wait any
longer go to meundies.com Joey right now
for 20 off your first order that's me on
these.com right now for 20 off your
first order and free shipping in Canada
and the United States what do you think
about that Lee I love it I I swear I
can't get the sweatpants the the
underdog the unknown hero of me undies
yeah no those red ones I have they're
all [__] purpose I only wearing my
North Bergen shirt I'm throwing [__]
heat you know what I'm saying how you
doing Louie Gomez I'm good man you're
looking around the room you're hearing
dragons and [__] I can see that look in
your audio starting to look like Ada
Fernandez uh I've been drinking the
hidden water here for a month in fact
we're only down to one bottle I think
they sent this 30. whatever flavor I
mean this is great stuff you know you
should drink eight glasses of water a
day but who really does coffee so the
energy drinks this that why don't you
just drink some more water because it's
bland hey I'm the same boat you want
something that tastes good here's the
solution drink hint water instead you
know you should drink eight glasses of
water a day but who really does nobody
why because it's boring that's why you
got to go to hit water okay it was
started by Cara golden after her fourth
child she was overweight she had
terrible acne she felt awful she was
drinking 10 of those diets so there's a
day like Lee
she started drinking water but she
wouldn't like it because it was boring
but what options were this juice is full
of calories and no calorie drinks of
garbage that's why she started hitting
water hint this pure infused with the
taste of fresh fruit with drinking water
isn't boring they have flavors to suit
any palate watermelon peach mango
grapefruit hey it's Christmas time this
is a great [__] gift okay no sugar no
chemicals just great tasting all natural
fruit flavored water both health and
self magazines have named hint water the
best flavored water because they know
how important drinking plenty of water
is to your health all right now do me a
favor please right now for the holidays
get a single variety pack shipped
directly to your door including three
bottles of each hints more popular
flavors pineapple watermelon crisp apple
and blackberry normally 24 bucks I'm
gonna give it to you for 15 at
drinkhint.com church again normally 24
for three bottles of each of their most
popular flavors pineapple watermelon
crisp apple and blueberry blackberry
normally 24 I'm giving it to you for 15
at drink hot
drinkhint.com church again that's drink
hemp
h-i-n-t.com slash church again
drinkhint.com church happy holidays to
you bad [__] and as always I
want to thank Anna the major sponsor of
the show whether it's the shroom Tech
sport
or the hemp Force protein they're always
on point and always changing go to their
website go to island.com right now and
look at the selection of supplements
they have and I can't help you with the
metal but as far as supplements I'll
give you ten percent off and you'll get
to rock and roll and deliver it to your
door Mr Gomez always a pleasure to see
you my brother Mr Syed you bad
[__] always a pleasure to see
you what are you doing this weekend I'm
going to a pug show what is it
again with Johnny Rock and his
girlfriend we're gonna try to do that
you couldn't avoid that [__] call
like it's a call from [__] uh Hitler
right
you see that number come up don't even
answer you don't want to go to the
movies with nobody how old are we now a
rival what are you gonna have with a
propeller and [__] I don't know are you
supposed to have a couple friends
friends I don't know that's a double
date like a half a [__] that holds hands
and you're giggle on each other's stupid
jokes well they get a couple swab huh
yeah he won't do that come on Lee you
wouldn't do that I I don't I don't think
it'd be me you'd have to convince to be
very honest I think it'd be the
oh yeah I actually would
because then I you always forget that
your girlfriend has to do it too so
that's not gonna happen yeah put the
goddamn music on have a great weekend I
love you [__] stay black we love
you [__]
my brother
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
all right
[Music]